e
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have
several Senate bills that we're going to
be hearing testimony on today but before
we do that I'd like you to please ask
I'd like to ask you to please join me in
Allegiance agents to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
it stands one nation God indivisible
everyone the first bill that we'll be
hearing about this morning is Senate
Bill 355- FN and Senator Anis I guess
could not be with us this morning but he
is ay represented by Grant bossy welcome
Mr
bossy
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the committee happy crossover week uh
my name is Grant bossy Deputy Chief of
Staff to the New Hampshire Senate and
I'm here to introduce Senate Bill 355 on
behalf of Senator Dan Enis the Bill's
Prime sponsor cyto megavirus or CMV is
known as the stealth virus you may have
never heard of it but it's actually
quite common in fact many of us may be
infected with CMV and never even know it
that's because for most healthy people
CMV has no symptoms most of them will
never develop symptoms if you've got a
compromised immune system though CMV can
be very serious in fact it's the most
common cause of hearing loss in children
it can also lead to blindness
developmental disabilities cerebal paly
and epilepsy this leaves pregnant women
and their babies most at risk one in
every 200 babies will be born with CMV
the baby usually doesn't show any
obvious symptoms but they can develop
serious health problems months or even
years after birth knowing that a newborn
has CMV can make a world of difference
should they develop those problems they
can be given antiviral medications and
more frequent hearing and vision tests
SB 355 as amended by the Senate would
direct the Department of Health and
Human Services to provide information on
the importance of early detection of CMV
to the newborn screening program under
RSA
13210 warning parents to be wary of CMV
symptoms addition it would require DHHS
to update the HHS oversight committee on
targeted newborn screening for CMV we
know the RIS of cnv to our newest
Granite Staters knowing an infection is
present can give parents and their
doctors the advanced warning they need
to provide timely and effective
treatment I would defer questions people
with more medical knowledge than I
possess but if you have questions for
Senator inis I'll make sure to get you
an answer thank you for your
consideration of Senate Bill
355 okay are you taking any questions at
all or uh if you have questions for
Senator Senator inis I can make sure you
get an answer I likely will not be able
to answer them here and now do we have
any questions to convey to Senator inis
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman um I I'd just be curious to
know who we have that'll be answering
questions just to make sure that we can
ask what's necessary um do we have
medical providers that have signed up to
speak now we have people from the
Department
um yes okay then I will save my my
question for the medical I just wanted
to make sure that things didn't go unas
so thank
you okay anything else to convey to
Senator
bosy also signed up to speak is Ben
Association
sorry morning Mr chairman I'm just going
to take a second to hand out my pile for
sure uh good morning everyone my name is
for the record my name is Ben Bradley
I'm the vice president of state
government relations for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association um we're
very appreciative of the sponsor's
effort to bring attention to this really
important issue and our member hospitals
remain committed to participating in the
new born screening program um RSA 132
colon 10A established the newborn
screening program and the requirements
for determining which disorders would be
screened at Birth as part of the program
requirements the newborn screening
advisory committee was established which
is responsible for studying conditions
to be included in the screening panel
the Department of Health and Human
Services Division of Public Health
Services um who is here today I believe
manages the program and convenes an
advisory committee on which the Hospital
Association has a seat and appoints a
designate from a hospital to participate
while this bill doesn't
um uh require uh screening under the uh
newborn screening program uh it does
take
um uh important steps to bring awareness
and information from the Department of
Health and Human Services on this
condition uh we initially had concerns
with the bill as introduced which have
since been resolved by an amendment
passed in the Senate and we look forward
to working with the Department of Health
and Human Services on providing
additional information about CMV
screening to the Health and Human
Services oversight committee thanks for
the opportunity to provide comments on
355 and I'm happy to take
questions representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
Broadley for being here this morning uh
my question is how are infants screened
for CMV so my understanding is when um
newborns are screened for hearing
um they have a hearing screening um and
if that screening is positive for
hearing loss um then our uh member
Hospital our birthing hospitals would um
screen for CMV but I also think that
there are other experts who may have
some additional insight into what the
requirements are for screening of CMV
and how um we can try to track it
early I have a follow sure followup um
thank you and as a followup um would it
be possible to share what you actually
I'll go to the the hearing reports from
the Senate to see what your concern was
that it was removed so thank you thanks
other
questions representative
Weber thank you um is it possible that
some of the concerns were resolved by
changing this from requiring the
screening which is how I assume the bill
came in yes um to um Pro providing more
information and and some protocols yeah
among other things I would say that that
was our um main concern uh you know the
advisory committee for these um
screening panels has been the
traditional mechanism for determining
what would be appropriate to include and
not include um and so we felt that um it
was most appropriate for that mechanism
the advisory committee to be making
those determinations rather than the
legislature trying to come up with a um
specified process or requirement in
statute
other
questions seeing none oh representative
not thank you for taking my question um
is there an estimate of how many
children go DEA because they have this
know I don't have those numbers but
there may be some other experts
somewhere there exist those yes I'm
quite sure I'll bar them out thank you
okay
okay other
you
also signed up to speak is Courtney
Keane from the health and human
Services you push the button to the
microphone there you go thank you good
morning chair McDonald and members of
the committee my name is Courtney Keen
I'm the administrator for the newborn
screening programs in the Department of
Health and Human Services Division of
Public Health Service I have direct
oversight of the newborn screening
program and a newborn hearing screening
program I am pleased to provide
information about Senate Bill
355 relative to newborn screening for
cyto Migo virus or CMV I would like to
thank senator inis for bringing
attention and awareness of CMV through
this legislation the department is in
support of the bill as amended by the
Senate uh the Department's newborn
screening program is responsible for
assuring all infants born in New
Hampshire are screened for 37 heritable
disorders clinical congenital heart
defects in newborn hearing the goal of
newborn
screening is early identification for
timely treatment and
intervention as mentioned before CMV is
the most common infectious birth effect
in the United States um infants born
with CMV which is one in five will have
long-term health problems such as
hearing loss Developmental and motor
delay delay loss micro micral and
seizures um and CMV is transmitted to
the fetus during
pregnancy um C 355 would direct the
newborn screening program to increase
awareness of CMV for expecting parents
and
providers um it would provide technical
assistance to hospitals who
independently and voluntarily conduct
targeted screening for cnv using urine
or saliva there's four hospitals that
currently do this
um and lastly the department will be
required to report its efforts on
increasing awareness education and
targeted CMV screening as part of the
program's annual report and there is no
fiscal impact to the department I want
to say thank you for the opportunity to
provide testimony today and I'd be happy
to answer any
questions representative
Weber thank you if you know and feel
free to say you don't if you don't um do
you have any sight as to why the newborn
screening um the committee that that
looks at these have determined not to
include this with the other ones so this
test is best conducted from the year in
the saliva of the infant so the blood
spot test is which I think you're
referring to it's not the best method
for testing for
sing so that 37 heritable disorders
that's using the blood so the would be
tested using urine and saliva for CMV so
so they're already may I follow sure
follow I'm I'm just remembering any
number of other bills that we've heard
in this committee where there is a
particular condition that somebody wants
to have added to the panel of tests that
are done and we have tried to refer
people to the newborn screening panel
and they've said well went there and
they said no and I I'm trying to find
out what the status is with this within
the panel and and and
how if if screening is already done
under what hospices I get it am I right
in thinking it's entirely voluntary at
this time yes okay so hospitals
voluntarily do this so it is not so
there's a recommended uniform screening
panel okay it that's what I was talking
about yeah okay it has not been approved
by that yet okay so New Hampshire has
not even entertained this conversation
because we go based on what is
recommended recommended by this
recommended uniform screening panel at
the
time our representative chapero thank
you Mr chairman if you would indulge my
ignorance about the um new board
screening program what does the newborn
screening program actually do do they
actually do screenings or do they
provide information to other medical
providers who do screening so the
newborn screening program is comprised
of blood spot so they do test infants
for 37 heritable
disorders yep all infants sorry um uh
newborn hearing screening so we test
every babies's for hearing and then
critical congenital heart defects so we
test all babies for that and this is
done within the 48 72 hours after
birth where where does that get done at
the hospital okay so the DHHS through
this program does it
at at at the hospitals yep okay so the
hospitals conduct all the screenings and
then they report to us okay the result
okay that's Rel true thank you very much
y representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
and being able to provide information if
a child is found to have CMV how does
the treatment of that child change based
diagnosis I can't answer that entirely
but I can answer a part of that so there
is Treatment available for infants with
CMV it's going to be specific on the
child and the provider what they
recommend okay as a followup follow up
so as a followup um I it sounds like
there's antivirals um if it's possible
to find out the number of children
needed to treat with those antivirals to
prevent a problem we just want to make
sure that children aren't overtreated
for something that may not cause
problems so if it's possible to get a
follow up on that I'd appreciate it yes
and I will say that children who are
asymptomatic typically aren't treated so
there has to be present
symptoms follow sorry and one more
followup so if a child develops shows
symptoms of one of the of CMV there are
they already tested for CMV if they show
symptoms it depends on at the hospital
level if they choose to test them or not
so there are four hospitals that do test
for CMV B based on hearing uh failing
the hearing screening the second time um
for those who are in more critical
condition the nicku uh Special Care
nurseries can test for cnv on their
own I can one more follow follow sorry
no this it is complex and that's why I
didn't want to ask a really big
complicated question do you know if
that's already in the guidelines that
are required for required for the
hospitals to follow for the joint
accreditation and everything else to be
licensed as a hospital so that if a
child shows those symptoms they need to
be screened for SE that would cause that
I don't know that answer I'll follow up
on that thank you other
questions saying none okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Elizabeth
triny hi good morning chairman and
McDonald uh members of the committee my
name is Elizabeth Sergeant I'm here from
shampan Capital group um a government
relations firm here in conquered and I'm
here to testify in support of the bill
for the New Hampshire Academy of
ideology uh Carolyn jury is the
president she couldn't appear before you
but she has submitted written testimony
that is coming around um I'll just I
won't read her testimony but uh we'll
just highlight um a couple of points CMV
is a common virus that often causes no
or few mild symptoms in adults and is
generally not well known um according to
CDC surveys only one in 10 women of
childbearing age have ever even heard of
it however if a woman contracts the
virus during her pregnancy it can have
lifelong serious problems for her child
most children known to have CMV at Birth
do not show any symptoms four out of
five show none and then so I'll um and
then she talks about infants who do show
symptomss are at a higher risk for
developing intellectual disability
language delays poor physical
coordination weakness hearing loss in
either one or both ears or seizures and
then she goes on to say the benefits of
very early ID
identification um can go a long way to
help the child's development progress in
the areas of need um and in closing so
she asked that the bill ought to pass I
will say representative Lon an answer to
your question and I looked through my
folder she adjusted her testimony last
night based on the bill as amended in
her original testimony which we'll send
to the committee and also she could be
available to answer any questions we
were thinking based on how it got
amended that um she didn't uh need to
come in person but she did
say um congenital CMV cause sensory
nuring hearing losses also unpredictable
in its course is a progressive loss that
worson over over time this can happen
very quickly mild to profound profound
HL in 2 years not be present at birth
but show a delayed onset which can occur
anytime generally within the first seven
years Andor the loss can continue to
worsen slowly through the Adolescent
years in order to confirm the virus's
presence the screening must be within
the first two to three weeks of birth by
collecting a urine sample like you heard
once identified Physicians can treat the
virus to to potentially reduce the
severity of any residual conditions
again underscoring the need for early
identification and monitoring so I will
submit she's got some more details that
might answer your question better we'll
submit this original testimony as well
and I may not be able to answer
questions but I can get them to Caroline
thank you representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you so much
for proactively answering that um if you
could have her get back to us with
information about I see that she says
that these would be reasonable First
Steps in the process I'd like to know
what the rest of the steps are in the
process and I'd like to understand um
what the treatment would be for a child
who is diagnosed with this because um
and what the consequences are from that
process yeah that sounds great and she's
listening in so we'll have her formulate
a written answer to the committee
fantastic thank you thank you
representative
not also I'm curious to see how many
children have been affected okay great
yeah we'll numbers to go along with okay
Weber one further statistic that I'd
like to see based on the other two
inquiries is the number of children
infected and then the number of children
who are
symptomatic okay great because it sounds
to me like there's a huge difference in
that me too that way we'll have the
whole Spectrum going around thank
you um thank you and um within that
similar to the number who are
symptomatic if she knows the number
needed to treat to prevent the hearing
loss that would be
helpful it thank you other
questions seeing none thank you very
much I have my homework thank you no one
else has signed up to testify does
anyone else wish to testify in this
fill representative of mapo can you tell
us on the blue sheet how many signed up
in favor and
opposed it's sorry to do that to you but
help okay all right thank
you representative Lon and online there
were zero in support into a post when
the attached
testimony okay all right if there's no
one else here to testify for on uh 355
FN I'm going to close the public hearing
on that bill and open the public hearing
on H SV 349 and recognize the crime
sponsor Senator Whitley good
morning uh good morning Mr chair and
good morning members of the committee
I'm sort of uh going going back and
forth with represent Shapiro he was just
in front of my committee HHS in the
Senate also meeting right now for the
record my name is Becky Whitley and I'm
honored to serve New Hampshire Senate
District 15 which includes the wonderful
communities of conquered Bo Penacook and
hopkington this morning I have SB 349
for your
consideration just as a little bit of
background the contents of this bill
were actually included in the New
Hampshire mom nibus last year um this is
a bill uh it was s SP 175 last year the
Senate passed that bill unanimously as
is our practice then we tabled it for
inclusion into the budget into hp1 uh
and hb2 however it got lost this portion
got lost in the shuffle and it did not
make it in into hb2 inadvertently so
very simply this bill simply adds a duty
to the existing wellness and primary
prevention Council that has been created
by this legislature and what it does is
asks them to study how New Hampshire can
reduce barriers improve access and
create a system of voluntary access to
uh home visiting so this committee may
know from years past the legislature has
discussed the benefits of Home visiting
it's something that we've expanded
access to in the medic program I will
let the folks behind me talk about this
service and how important it is to new
families um but just briefly we know
that uh the service has really proven to
uh improve lives and improve health
outcomes it's also been shown to pay for
itself financially over time and reduced
health education and criminal justice
costs uh as this committee may know well
currently only those eligible for New
Hampshire Medicaid have reliable access
to home visiting I will say I had my
baby 10 plus years ago at uh conquered
hospital and I did have access to home
visiting and it was a game Cher I I feel
lucky that I have a lot of resources
available to me a very supportive family
I was healthy my baby was healthy yet
home visiting was uh an incredible
resource that I um had about a week
after I gave birth my son um had a
tongue tie he was having trouble nursing
of course that's terrifying for new moms
if you can all go back to that feeling
the mom's in the room home visitor the
home visitor came uh she took care of my
son she took care of me um and I will
never forget that visit um in my pajamas
about a week after giving birth at home
so um this bill would allow the existing
wellness and PR and primary prevention
Council uh Who members are here can tell
you their work but it's an existing
Council that does a lot of great work um
and it will allow them to sort of study
what are the barriers right now to more
moms accessing this service how do we
improve access and how do we create a
system so that more more parents of of
newborns uh can get this critical
service I respectfully ask the committee
to support SB 349 I'm happy to take any
questions but there are folks from the
wellness and primary prevention Council
who can speak to their work and also uh
speak to home visiting in more detail
thank you very much representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
senator wetley for being here with us um
I also had that same crisis too my
crisis was at 11 o'clock at night and
the monthly lche meeting was in town the
next day so that was thank I appreciate
all of this um my question is more to
you because you deal with more the
limited resources and the choices we
have to make in the legislature than um
than this Council needs to with our
shortage of uh medical and Healthcare
Providers how does this filter into the
fact that we're just trying to make sure
that we have the providers available at
our at our facilities in order to see
patients see families see babies which
is done in a much more time efficient
way when the families are coming to them
and how do we look at those resources
when we're expecting them to travel from
home to home and um deal with that in in
our in our current issue of Workforce
yeah thank you for that question it's a
real problem our perinatal Workforce is
strapped part of the New Hampshire
Omnibus was to take a holistic look at
the perinatal Workforce but it's a real
problem and so I think those issues that
I that you have identified Workforce
barriers Insurance barriers other
barriers that's exactly what this bill
is intended to address and have this the
group that really knows best to study it
I know that you all are on many study
committees as am I um we really felt
like um at this point uh we need the
experts who are working in the field to
sort of study through and look through
and identify these barriers and then
come back to the legislature to provide
some recommendations that's what this
Council already does they're already
designated to look at those prevention
strategies and come back to the
legislature um and so they were a good
uh it was actually at the suggestion of
the Senate President to have them
continue to do that work thank
you other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you very much and excuse me as I uh run
back to my own committee we understand
much I'm not going to try to pronounce
this last name but Rebecca from wellness
and primary prevention Council I'll let
you uh I rather than mispronounce it I
figur I'll let you pronounce thank you
it's a nice polish last name so my name
is Rebecca boy kovsky and I am in my
professional role the child and family
policy director at new Futures but I'm
here today as the chair of the wellness
and primary prevention Council
representative
wber the last name sure it's w i t k w s
k i welcome no problem um so I'm here as
the chair of the wellness and primary
prevention Council to to give a little
bit more depth to the facts that Senator
Whitley laid out first and foremost I
want to say that the wellness and
primary prevention council is a
voluntary um Council but as a membership
we all do support this bill the wppc has
been around since
1999 so we have been working in
coordination and service to the state of
New Hampshire for over 25 years Not Me
Myself And um the goal really is to
support a system of primary prevention
in New Hampshire and as part of the
outline duties the wellness and primary
prevention council is charged to look at
how we can improve the system make
recommendations around funding and look
at barriers and
inefficiencies I want to um underscore
that what is outlined in Senate Bill 349
we have done before actually in 2017 the
W PPC was led by Senator um I mean
representative John fathergill who
proposed um with former represent
representative skip Baran a bill that
would charge the wppc to look at how we
could strengthen Family Resource Centers
so over the course of the year a number
of years recommendations were made to
this legislature and now we have a
facilitating organization and last year
in a bipartisan effort this legislature
um uh appropriated historic funding to
the system because it's been efficient
so I think when we look at primary
prevention Family Resource Centers are
important but also for maternal Health
how are we helping our new moms and
babies and home visiting is a really key
aspect to that and I'm representative
lay on your question about how does this
um impact efficiencies or helping you
know with regard to hospitals we know we
have a um uh lack of access to maternal
Healthcare in rural areas so
understanding how home visiting can help
or reduce barriers is really important
for our state so I'll just emphasize
that the wppc has been here for a long
time um we are a well organized and
equipped body to take this question
study it and provide back to the
legislature a number of recommendations
so we hope that you will consider this
bill and urge you ought to pass and I'm
here happy to answer any other questions
you may have any questions
representative
McKay thank you Mr chairman uh the title
is voluntary is there such a thing as an
involuntary
no there isn't um I think the term
voluntary home visiting is meant to
convey that it's up to the parents
whether or not you have a home visitor
um come to your house but there is no
mandatory home visiting thank you other
much also signed up to speak is I think
it's Brianna Hamill from new future
FES and I'm not sure if I pronounce that
correctly I apologize I also really bad
well I I know I'm not in a position to
criticize anyone's handwriting so I try
not to do that so my last name is ha
Cole
okay um hello my name's Brianna hle I am
the legal policy fellow at new futures
Futures is a nonprofit organization that
works to yeah could you get sorry there
we go um yeah have a lot of yeah yeah I
can tell um new future supports SP 349
because it works towards access to home
visiting home visiting is important
because it helps both um development of
the baby and the parents and they can
also do screening for postpartum
depression which can reduce maternal
mortality um current Curr only
7.2% of people who qualify for the
current home visiting program actually
receive
um home visiting and so the study will
help home visiting thank
you any questions representative King
thank you Mr chair how does one qualify
for it thank you um it's through an um
for the Medicaid it's through income
base so lower income families
qualify other questions
seeing no okay thank you representative
Weber sorry I just thought of one which
was
um are you doing any kind of work um
Outreach work to let people know that
the program
exists um or is that one of the things
that's going to be looked at in the
report I believe so okay I'll withdraw
that then thank
you other
you
also signed up to speak is McKenzie
Nicholson from Mom's
morning you have like written testimony
also to pass I do should I can I wait to
pass it out I sure I was taught by
someone who taught me it's very
distracting to pass it out in the
beginning okay so if I may thank you
good morning chairman McDonald and
members of the committee thank you for
um listening to me today my name is
McKenzie Nicholson I'm the senior
director of Mom's rising in New
Hampshire
I have the distinct privilege of
attending your committee after attending
New Hampshire children's trust um
legislative breakfast where they talked
about primary prevention for child abuse
this morning and I find it ironic that
we're talking about home visiting today
technically we don't allow props oh
apologies that's
okay it's it's pretty innocuous but some
props aren't so yeah or you see them um
but anyways just brought it by to show
you that a lot of folks are talking
about wellness and primary prevention um
today so very honored to be here to
speak for your committee I'm sure you
won't be surprised to hear me say that
Mom's Rising really cares about moms not
just moms but anybody who's ever had a
mom or loved a mom too um we represent
thousands of moms across the granite
state and we focus primarily here on uh
creating positive change in the granite
state in the early care and education
maternal health and workplace Justice
spaces um we bring the voices of women
and mothers directly to our elected lead
ERS which is why I'm here before you
today but speaking from personal
experience and having a a little one
myself I can tell you that those very
first moments with your new baby are
some of the most exciting they're full
of a lot of first that first breath that
first smile eventually that first step
but at the same time they're truly some
of the most terrifying even when you
read all the books of what to expect
supporting new moms and birthing people
and their babies during those magical
first moments is critical in
strengthening our communi in promoting
infant and maternal health and positive
parent child relationships as you've
heard my colleague say home visiting is
an effective tool that ensures that
families with young children have access
to the support that they need to build a
strong foundation in life for well-being
and success trained professionals work
with the family to grow parenting skills
create social support systems and
connect them to other resources these
personalized supports meet families
literally where they're at by meeting
them in the home which helps reduce
barriers to participation such as
transportation and child care which we
know in a state like ours can be very
challenging um this comprehensive
approach helps create healthier moms and
babies stronger parent child bonds lower
rates of child abuse and neglect more
positive parenting practices earlier
development of language and literacy
skills and improved School Readiness
safer homes and increased rates of
Parental
employment as Senator Whitley mentioned
um there are studies that have shown
that home visiting it can yield
significant return on adment um anywhere
between a80 to $5.70 for every dollar
spent by intervening early and
preventing costly problems down the road
um home visiting is a fin financially
and fiscally smart decision we do use
Medicaid dollars to fund some folks
access as representative king um
questioned earlier um to home visiting
through the Medicaid Program in 2021 my
data might be a little old here but we
estimate that we served about 6.5%
children under three with um eligible
incomes So Below 150% of the federal
poverty level who would have been
eligible and that figure Falls below the
national average of about 8% of eligible
children in the Medicaid Program having
access to home visiting um overall
though in the state only 1% of zero to
two year olds in New Hampshire um
receive a home visit from a home visitor
I've included in my testimony a story
from a member from sutt New Hampshire
which emphasizes um how valuable home
visiting was for her and her medically
complicated um preey who came home when
her husband was away at work um she
details how without this she may not
have survived so iure I hope that you'll
take a look at it and um just let you
know that Mom's Rising is proud to
support senel 349 as a piece of the
Omnibus that we passed last year and
some great work that we did on maternal
Health um we should be doing everything
everything we can to make sure that moms
and babies have a healthy start in life
and so we ask for your support for
Senate Bill 349 and I'm happy to take
any questions any questions
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for coming here
um when you were referencing the meeting
this morning um I'm I'm curious how
these home visits intersect with child
abuse definitely so part of Home
visiting is par positive parenting skill
building um so getting to families in
some of those very vulnerable first
moments as parents um
is really critically important for
teaching parents what to expect um how
to deal with a baby who won't stop
crying in the middle of the night who's
maybe KY um this is what primary
prevention at its finest it starts at
the very beginning uh right as babies
are
born representative
paza thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I wonder if parents
are aware that home visit may end up in
remote removal of the baby if there some
signs of neglect as you mentioned I'm
not sure I don't have the data around
that uh to support that claim but I can
follow up with
you other
questions representative
Shapero Mr chairman can I ask who else
has signed up I'm not sure who my
question is would be most appropriate no
one else has signed up to Tes can I take
have a question then sure go
ahead thank you for taking this question
I'm not sure sure you're the right
person to answer it but
um when I look under RSA 126 M3 it says
the intent of this act is to encourage
facilitate and promote primary
prevention and early intervention
efforts and it goes on a little bit so
my question really
is isn't the intent of this um wellness
and primary C Care Council already to do
exactly what we're suggesting that it
does um so so the question therefore
would
be what will change because of this
specific
legislation chairman McDonald if I can
divert to my colleague from the W sure I
you thanks for the question um how it is
different is primary prevention is a
very large world of um different
interventions we can do the direction
and instruction of what the wellness and
primary prevention Council should study
and issue a to as a report to the
legislature is really a clear directive
that we could do on our own but we're a
voluntary body and so this request comes
from the Omnibus last year discussions
with um you know senators and
representatives about what they the body
should be doing so supposedly we could
do it on our own but we look for
direction really from the legislature
and half for the past 25 years so thank
you other
questions seeing none okay thank
you and I just received another pink
card Athena Cody from the Department of
Services good morning chairman McDonald
and members of the committee my name is
Athena Cody I'm with the Department of
Health and Human Services Division of
Public Health Services um and there I
work within the Bureau of family health
and nutrition where we oversee uh two
Statewide home visiting programs and I'm
here to answer any questions but I also
submit a testimony um via email thank
you any questions Miss Cody
representative
Palazo uh uh are you aware of many cases
when Childs were removed from families
as a as a followup for home visit
because we heard about child abuse and
about neglect and that uh home visit is
one of the ways how it could be
discovered uh thank you for the question
uh just as stated a number of the
activities that a home visitor will um
work with the family on is really to try
to mitigate try to avoid any abuse or
neglect um act activities so working
towards things like early screening um
helping to connect that family reducing
barriers to accessing things like Mental
Health or substance use treatments um if
there's a barrier around Transportation
trying to really help to mitigate that
um in New Hampshire but not just New
Hampshire State w u Nationwide um
neglect is one of those primary um
buckets of child abuse and neglect um
but that incompasses a lot of things um
including um things that can relate to
Poverty to to not having enough of um
concrete support so really home visiting
is a great um opportunity for families
to have access to you know positive
parenting techniques attachment but also
connection to Community Based Services
that are already available um and just
helping to really mitigate those
barriers other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you and no one else has signed up to
testify does anyone else wish to testify
on a Senate Bill Fe
49 seeing N Miss Dyer can you uh get us
the blue sheet please or give it to
representative Shapiro
representative Shapiro if you would mind
maybe representative Weber was coming
sure see in favor
okay okay thank you very
much representative Le and online it
says there's nine that support but
somebody double entered so it's eight in
support and two a post okay thank you
and with that I'm going to close the
public hearing on Senate Bill 349 and
open the public hearing on Senate Bill
409 FN and recognize Senator
Apprentice recognize Senator friend is
sponsor Senator Apprentice on her way do
we
know
we do have
it yes um apparently Senator Apprentice
her okay yeah if you could
great if Senator Apprentice comes in
Weber good morning committee members my
name is Lucy Weber I represent cheser 5
the Connecticut River towns of Walpole
and S actually s isn't quite Connecticut
River but that that direction um I am
here to introduce as a courtesy to
Senator Apprentice Senate Bill 409 f
relative to reimbursement for ambulance
services under the State Medicaid plan
uh this is a matter that we've heard a
little bit about before and I'm looking
forward to hearing about it again but I
hope nobody's going to ask me questions
thank you he thank you representative
Weber okay uh signed up to speak on this
uh John Williams and Rob Barry from the
Department of Health and Human Services
at least I don't I don't see Mr Barry
but I do see attorney Williams so
welcome back chairman McDonald and
members of the Health Human Service
elderly Affairs committee uh for the
record I am John Williams the
legislative director for Health Human
Services and I have to say there was
some magical scheduling happening here
today because the exact subject matter
is now currently being heard in the
Senate Health and Human Service
committee on hp56 which your committee
entertained earlier uh prior to U
getting close CL crossover so that's
where attorney Rob Barry is right now uh
I am here uh to uh let you the committee
know that the department is supportive
of the concept I'm being very careful
with the word supportive of the concept
of what's trying to be achieved here um
the provider Community for uh
Transportation around ambulances is
critically important and they've
identified a gap where they're not being
paid as you know from the prior bill
under certain circumstances so what um
this bill before you attempts to do is
to make whole to the extent possible for
those particular Services uh one item
that I bring to your attention that is
glaringly missing from the bill is the
requisite uh state federal match that
would be required for us to actually pay
for these additional cost uh to the
state so my request to this committee
even though you're a policy committee
you can't do the policy unless you have
the resources of doing it that we would
be required to getting an appropriation
of $1 million uh for a total fund
appropriation including Federal match
50/50 match uh for a grand total of $2
million
total funds so that concludes my
testimony I am not an expert in this
area because he is downstairs testifying
on the other bill but I can certainly
take back questions from the committee
okay uh representative representative
Weber and then representative
Leon thank you so much for being here
and um I guess my
concern if you were part of the
discussions on this if you could help me
work
through uh the language on lines 8 and N
which says providers shall be eligible
for Medicaid reimbursement under this
paragraph only when all the following
requirements are met and as I read those
requirements some of them appear to me
to be somewhat contradictory in the fact
that one of them actually includes
people who are dead so um I'm I'm
wondering if you have any comments on
how to resolve A B C D and E and F uh
some of which are are clear and fairly
distinct but
um the concerns I have are sort of
um you have to both agree you have to
have the competency all of that makes
perfect sense but
[Music]
um I I just wonder if there are times
when some of these are going to get in
the way of others of
them and wondering why including when
resuscitation efforts are
terminated um you have to agree that
there's not a need I mean you have to
both agree that there's not a
need uh but but it also seems to talk
about when you actively
refuse there might be a need and you
refused and you had already been treated
and that would be disqualifying and so
but I see Senator Apprentice so maybe
I'll hold that for her and take you off
the
hook uh hi I'm coming and lay this is
robberry General Council division
medicate I was just testifying h568
which is of course is the companion bill
uh and we certainly would seed our time
to Senator appris and again we support
strongly the concept of legislation just
looking for the necessary State uh
General funds to match so we can make
this happen thank
you representative Leon did you have a
question for the department or um
Department thank you one of the areas
that was noted as lacking in this one is
when somebody comes for a fall and lift
assist somebody that is only able to
stay in their home because um local
emergency services are able to lift them
when necessary would it be possible to
find out if that would be permitted
under the state and federal match and
what the appropriation would be
necessary should that be the case yes
that is part of the contingency of
language here in the bill but we can
absolutely find out whether that would
you any other questions for the
representative
TZ uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I
I'm a little I don't remember the
details since we have had these
conversations previously my
understanding was that the uh ambulance
services are concerned about not getting
paid unless there's transport but
there's a lot a lot of potential other
things including what representa wber
pointed out a specific stream of
potential events what about they just um
show up and do something that's not all
these things and then and then
additionally I don't remember where we
ended up with what do other payers do
like is this going to put us in
alignment with what all the other
insurers do or does how does this differ
like I'm not completely up to speed on
what other insurers are doing I'm more
in the Medicaid space um but I think
Senator Apprentice can probably better
answer that question about the the
drafting of the bill I will say the
department
did like the way s SP 49 was drafted and
as it came out of the Senate as amended
uh apart from the appropriation
language other questions for the
gentlemen
and welcome Senator Apprentice please
please no by all means please come
forward I know you're a busy lady this
morning just I have all the time in the
world at this point good morning and
thank you chair McDonald and members of
house
HHS uh I U yes I had another bill to
introduce and we had a lengthy
discussion but I'm glad to be here so
I'm here today to introduce Senate Bill
409 which I know you have heard a house
version of so let me uhu let me tell you
a little bit about this but for the
record my name is Suzanne prentis I'm
the state senator from District 5 that
rep representing 15 communities a large
part of Grafton part a large part of
Sullivan including representative
Palmer's Hometown and one community of
marac County the lovely uh town of the
new London so this bill I think as
you're aware would direct um would
direct the state of New Hampshire to
amend the Medicaid plan with the
approval of CMS so that patient or
emergency
responses When Calls for help come in
and there is a decision to not to
transport because the patient doesn't
want to be transported and there may
have been some care provided the patient
doesn't want to be transported and there
has been no care provided the patient
has been actively resuscitated and
unfortunately they um they were they've
been try actually they've tried to
actively resuscitate them but they were
unable to and so they've had to
terminate resuscitation on the scene
what we have found um in not just in New
Hampshire but throughout the country is
that with the exception of a few of the
private payers private insurance
carriers there hasn't been
reimbursement for treat and non-
transport so you may have heard of the
et3 project which was a federal
initiative under CMS was a pilot program
to evaluate this that got terminate
because it's there's a real need and
I'll tell you about the numbers in New
Hampshire but because this was ongoing
during the pandemic U and there were
multiple factors they decided to stop
the pilot program and so there's no real
data or no real action from Medicare so
we have to turn to the States and then
the private payers some of which are
already doing this and say what is it
that we can do to assist these
communities who are making these
responses who have people on call up 247
to do this work and then there is you
know no reimbursement for them U so this
is the the idea was to try to bring this
onto the state level deal with our own
State Medicaid plan see if we could get
that Amendment and even though it's not
a lot it's something versus the the
inability to collect anything right now
so here's what I do know after being in
this business for a lot longer than I um
for emergency medical services and I
ever thought that I um you know I when I
first started this I never thought 35
plus years I'd still be you know a
paramedic and you know working but here
we are so the demand for prehospital
medical care has grown and the
capabilities of those that are providing
care in your communities that has grown
as well um to meet the demand um and the
number of ambulances and Personnel that
are readily available we know that
hospitals are low on available beds and
are experiencing much of the same
Workforce shortage that the Emergency
Medical Services field is so our system
has been increasingly responding to the
needs of granite Staters that are not
life-threaten threatening um not
appropriate for transport they don't
want the transport to a hospital or
Unfortunately they were unable um to be
Rec itated these calls again they
require Personnel equipment Fuel and in
some cases they also require using
medical supplies that are on those
vehicles or come with those providers to
the scene presently again we can't build
Medicare U there are we can't build
Medicaid unless we you know pass this
legislation uh we do know that Anthem
does have a code and does allow for a
non-transport
a to bill for non-transport but through
this process we found that a lot of
Emergency Medical Service units didn't
even know that they could use that so
the system is it's GNA have to gear
itself up to change the way that it does
business not just if we pass this law
but now they're already talking about if
our you know if a patient has Anthem we
could actually bill for this and Anthem
kind of set the model in terms of the U
the hicp pick code that they used for us
to adopt into this discussion so under
medic I've already brought up that we
have the hipi code so let's talk about
um the situations that this could be
used in and what I did is I looked at
the New Hampshire patient care protocols
so this is what our emergency medical
responders are working with and try to
align this as closely as I could with
the protocol so the call has to be
originated through you know a 911 system
or go into sometimes they go into a
local emergency dispatch but it comes in
as an emergency call um the patient
consents to evaluation and treatment but
after that evaluation they choose that
they do not want to go thank you very
much they do not want to go to the
hospital um the licensed paramedic or
emergency medical technician and
patients agree that there is not a need
for transportation by an ambulance this
shall include again when resuscitation
efforts are terminated the patient does
not request an actively refuses
transport to an emergency department for
evaluation the patient is stable for
referral to a patient's position or
other community resource or again
unfortunately has passed away the
patient has the ability including the
mental capacity and transportation
resources to obtain assistance for
medically indicated followup I spent a
number of years working in emergency
departments including up in the Plymouth
area and here in Cong ConEd and there
would be times when patients would
arrive by private vehicle after
evaluation by an ambulance who has
responded and put those resources in but
they didn't need an ambulance so they
chose not to go but were able to consent
we capable and had a safe ride and came
to the emergency department in these
instances it's reasonable to assume that
a hospital bed may still be open for
another patient that needs it it's also
safe to assume that the cost of the
system including Medicade is less than
if charges for transportation for that
ambulance call were assessed as well as
to occupy that emergency department bed
an assessment from whatever level care
provider midlevel provider or a
physician and any test that they decide
that they are going to do that is going
to be more expensive than focusing on
these situations where the prehospital
community has been trained to do this
work and has a protocol to do this work
and I will add on here that whenever in
doubt there's we use something called
online medical control if you've ever
worked at an ambulance or in an
emergency department in these situations
many times the ambulance service will
call in and say this patient really
doesn't want to go here's my assessment
I'm comfortable sending them by private
vehicle are you good with that and the
physician confers or the nurse
practitioner or the physic physician's
assistant with the ambul and makes a
decision about where this where the best
the best possible disposition is for
this
patient uh providing for reimbursement
through Medicaid will bring some needed
relief to EMS to municipalities but most
importantly will keep patients who don't
need to be in a hospital out of the
hospital I am aware that Minnesota
Georgia sou Carolina and Arizona have
dedicated Medicaid dollars specifically
to this this type of initiative
according to the Department of safey
trauma and Emergency Medical Services
information system in 2022
total Statewide there were
216,000 106 calls for help when a
stadiums provider responded 59,000 of
those only 59,000 out of that were non-
transports where an assessment and some
kind of care took place and a
determination was made not to transport
that Pati again aligned with their
protocols so I'm I I understand that you
have heard a similar bill um and I'm
certainly pleased to or would be honored
to partner with the the sponsors of that
bill to try to shape this policy and get
it across the finish line so that we
can provide some reimbursement if CMS
agrees to this to these communities and
these ambulance services for their
Staffing for their equipment for their
work as well as keep Pat honor the
wishes of patients and keep them where
they need to be and the last thing I'm
going to say is that the way the system
is set up now it's highly connected to
transport so to get paid you have to
transport somebody but that doesn't mean
if they don't want to go you can't take
them that's that's kidnapping unless
they're you know unable to make a
decision for themselves I want to make
that clear but this is where the rub
comes in there's a better way to do this
and I'm suggesting a better way to do
this um and so I'm hoping for your help
and I'm happy to answer any questions
that you might have
representative Weber thank you for
coming and thank you for taking my
question uh which I was in the middle of
asking the wrong person arrive so
um my question is a drafting question I
mean I I understand all those
considerations that you have here but
the statute as it is currently before me
says on lines 8 and nine providers shall
be eligible for Medicaid reimbursement
under this paragraph only when all of
the following requirements are met and
they can't all be met in most conditions
particularly as I was in the course of
saying if somebody has not been able to
be resuscitated all of those other
things aren't going to happen uh so I
wonder if you would be concerned if we
draft that so that either either it can
be one of the following or perhaps take
a look I mean obviously anytime it
happens there there has to be proper
consent and and those kinds of things so
some of it I'm perfectly comfortable
having be mandatory but maybe it's it's
one from column A and one one or more
from column B um so if if that's okay
perhaps that's a conversation we could
go on having representative Weber thank
you for the question and it it should
it's a great catch you know you look at
things time and time again and then it
pops out at you so it should be you know
one or more there's a way that we can
work on the wording of this because some
of these stand alone and some of these
are in combination so I think that
that's a really important piece thank
you um I'd be happy to work with you on
that thank you representative Canon and
then representative
McKay I I sort of wanted to reinforce
reinforce representative Weber's concern
um having been uh in in a facility where
someone had overdosed in a in a restroom
and they had uh a friend that that
administered CPR but the fire department
and EMTs did show up to to assist and
the patient did respond to the CPR and
was was active the they were asked if
they wanted to be transported the answer
was no however this the question I had
because it it wouldn't fulfill the
number the letter F thing is that the
the individual was homeless and walked
away with their friend and as far as we
knew they had no method of
transportation uh so that that
particular item would not be fulfilled
um because they had no idea what would
happen to that individual when that
individual left the
premises go well thank you
representative Canon for raising this
one of the things I will share with you
is
uh oftentimes here here's the good news
is that we have um we have placed aeds
and we have placed Naran and we have
placed tourniquets in so many different
places that were actively able to engage
the public long before and the ambulance
service even gets there U most of those
cases with the exception I would say of
the Naran resuscitation U because I if
you're Prof profusely bleeding and need
a tourniquet or have suffered a sudden
cardiac rest for any other reason
medically indicated fall up is going to
require Transportation but there are
times um and it's not just with naram
but there are times when somebody um I
would say a DI even a diabetic is a
perfect example where you're able to
actually raise their blood sugar they
are completely competent they don't want
to go we can give them just like when
they would leave an Emergency Department
EMS can give them discharge
instructions but whether they do it or
not we can't make them we want them to
and we have to continue I think by doing
something like this I think it's a a lot
less threatening that they don't want to
go to the hospital we might be able to
ease them in to another place so I
appreciate what you're bringing forward
that needs to be tinkered but understand
that we just like when someone would
leave an emergency department they get a
list of here are the things to do for
medically necessary followup including
senior primary care provider did people
always do that unfortunately no but we
try our best but I just wanted to raise
it the way the way it's currently
written that that individual in that
case doesn't necessarily have
Transportation after they walk out of
the building they they also um received
Nar can from a local person in the
office thank you for raising that
representative representative McKay and
then representative
Shapiro thank thank you Mr
chairman I've recently had some
experience with ambulance use
unfortunately uh I I have absolutely no
memory of of people coming to get me or
where I went or and and uh all of this
refers to the patient consents over and
over again uh that and uh the the others
like
myself were not able to make any
consent uh at all um in fact uh I don't
remember the three days of was in the
hospital or what
happened and I didn't know at all why
they got an ambulance from someplace
over in Kean to take me from the
hospital to the nursing home which is
also in conquer so that all of these
references to the patient does this this
this and this I think many other people
have the same experience that I had that
that there was no ability on my part to
make any
decisions on my part and nobody in the
house to make any other decisions so
that it it seems that this is making
requirements that in some situations are
impossible so thank you representative
McKay and it's good to see you here and
well sorry that you had that experience
thank
you what what I would like to share with
you is that if you can't consent you
can't
say I you know I want um I don't if you
can't consent you either agree to the
treatment uh you know you agree or or
don't agree if you if you can't consent
then this doesn't apply to you because
you are so sick that you need other
protocols and other levels of care need
to be brought into your situation so
this is crafted very specifically for
people who don't who don't meet that
higher level of
illness or Acuity like they're super
sick that they need to go to to a
hospital this is for the folks that are
um
alert appropriately able to you know
answer questions about their
surroundings their conditions and can
say yes I want to go or no I don't want
to go follow follow is is there some
place that deals with people like me uh
that I I don't see that in this statute
that this seems to be for coherent
people at the moment and I don't see
anything that refers
to what happens when I wake up to say I
didn't want to go to that blank blankety
blank
so RSA 153a which governs Emergency
Medical Services enables the Department
of Safety in collaboration not even
collaboration they are required to have
a group of Physicians and mid-level
providers that actually write the care
protocols for all types of patients so
there is a a whole different document um
and set of training that would go with
those situations and that is again under
RSA 153a I don't remember the exact
citation anymore I used to but sfc 5900
was where you would find the reference
to the prot a very brief followup uh I
think I needed to vent a bit and it's
okay and I think representative Weber
explained that transport is handled in
other parts of legislation so thank you
very much anytime and again good to see
you here representative Shapero and then
representative Leon thank you Mr chair
um I think prior to your coming in first
of all thank you for bringing this bill
I know it's really important to you know
new Ambulance Service in in keen and um
I know it's important
for services all around the state which
are in Jeopardy and besides it just
seems illogical that it would work this
way
um so my question revolves around a
conversation that happened I think just
prior to you coming in the door which
was
um people from DHHS saying um one thing
that's missing in this bill is an
appropriation for $1 million to pay the
state um match for the additional
Medicaid that would be
necessary then in your testimony um you
talked about potential cost savings for
example
um you know somebody isn't transported
which means maybe they don't get further
tests that would be covered by Medicaid
um at the emergency room or perhaps they
don't get actually get admitted to the
hospital and um that Medicade
reimbursement for a stay at the hospital
is not necessary so you were referring
to cost
savings so my question is and this might
be really impossible to answer any idea
about what those cost savings are and
what are those cost savings mean in
terms of really having the need for an
additional $1 million appropriation
so thank you and good to see you again
this morning so I was able to get uh
receive from Henry Litman I'm looking
because we had a little bit of a shuffle
here through my well organized pile of
papers I was not able to get the
hospital costs but I was able to get the
ambulance cost if we just started to
talk about what it was to
transport by ambulance so hang on just a
second um I guess it was not I guess I
understand from director Litman that the
way that they would have to do the
breakdown um to get this by beds is
different like by regions and hos
hospitals it was it was simpler for him
to just focus in for me on the ambulance
side of this so let's say that um we
have an als1 an advanced life support so
they require say intravenous therapy or
cardiac monitoring that's going to be
$527
58 for that just that transport and that
doesn't include the ground mileage which
is
8.71 um and there might be other
supplies um so there's to consider that
and we don't have to apply to the entire
59,000 because not all of those are
Reach This level but start to think
about you know that's just for the
prehospital side the hospital side and I
say this in fairness and with respect is
going to be more costly so if I had an
exact I could do the tradeoff I was able
to at least look at the prehospital
numbers and have some comfort on what we
would be saving the system by keeping
these folks home and in terms of the
appropriation I mean this has been
through Senate Finance but I will Circle
back to my colleagues to make sure that
it is um that we've tightened that
up follow up thank you um so I I realize
it's very complicated to get a like a
total amount um or an estimated total
amount even um and and maybe the um
folks from DHHS would be better able to
answer this but is it your opinion that
whatever savings we do end up
estimating might um mean a reduction in
that new appropriation or is it kind of
different areas
different different
um you know different monies and so we'd
still need a full appropriation so we
can go back to director Litman and talk
to him represent it's my position that
what we would be investing in the non-
transports doesn't even cover what it
costs these communities to even just
staff and do the work as they're doing
so what we can the what the little that
would be broken up to give out would
still be less in total say of that
million dollars then what it's going to
cost if we transported all of those
people to the hospital that's okay and
you know if we want to so that that's my
position thank you you're welcome
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you senator for
bringing this and all of your experience
in this area when you were listing out
the the things that need to be covered
it seemed like there were different
specific categories and following what
representative Weber said it sort of
needs to be teased out into these
different category areas um because this
is so important um it doesn't make sense
to have the delay to put any of these
criteria into administrative roles but
because it's so important I think it
makes sense to get these different areas
done my question would be if you would
be interested in us working maybe
through work sessions or something else
just really to roll up our sleeves talk
about these different items and figure
out how we can break it out into
something that would meet these needs
that you've identified and specifically
outline those requirements so that we
can understand these areas of most
pressing need and make sure that we're
addressing them in clear language so
that it's not denied
thank you representative Leon for your
question I I would be I'm very open to
that um and I think that in having these
work sessions what we would want to do
is bring in somebody from the Department
of Safety that's the licensing agency
that coordinates with the development of
the patient care protocols and bring a
member of the medical control board in
and maybe one or two providers to work
with say whoever you assigned to this
including myself to to get the questions
answered that you need to see if there
needs to be additional language or we're
good to go where we are and as a
followup followup and then as a
follow-up since this is an early Bill
we'd have to make sure that we hit the
gas and do this pretty quickly is that
something you'd be able to maybe we we
can check calendars afterwards and see
if there's something we can get get on
so that we can we can address the
concerns that were raised around the
other Bill and maybe find a solution for
both bodies to adopt sure absolutely
thank you other questions represent
TZ and then representative colazo thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
my question
um so between uh the other version or
the you know the house version of this
issue and uh your really informative um
background that you've provided uh it's
clear there's a comprehensive list of
charges that are incurred and we also
have learned um that there's a lot of
concern about the ambulance company
staying float um and that they're
providing essential care in hospital
deserts and so uh you're you're really
good informative um uh what you
presented to us was really helpful to to
understand especially some of the data
that I don't think we'd heard previously
um the part for me that I would like to
understand better is the bigger picture
of what happens um because we had so
much interest every time we've uh
touched this bill uh from the uh
stakeholders
H what happens with um I I keep hearing
that patients get bills for ambulance um
from ambulance companies and so I don't
understand how that fits in with this I
know we're crafting a specific solution
just for Medicaid but it's helpful to
understand the bigger picture and I'm
wondering if you have that
information so like when do patients get
bill is it for the all these other costs
that they can't build Medicaid for or
how just just wondering if if we know
how that all fits together thank you
very much the question it's just my
daughter and I need to say sorry I'll
call you later um she's 27 and she so
I'm thankful that she still calls me all
the time um so this is a good thing now
your question so thank you very much for
the
question with the exception right now of
that we've been able to identify Anthem
none of these I go to your I you know I
receive a call for
help I respond as part of an ambulance
crew I assess you I provide maybe you
know again it's a diabetic emergency and
I provide care specific care for you uh
which I've done this many times
including making them their own peanut
butter sandwich from their kitchen once
they are like ready and you know to go
and they don't want to go um and maybe
I'll talk to a doctor or maybe I won't
at that point we're done there's no
mechanism for billing but we have we've
you know we've answered the call we've
provided the care we've end of the
supplies which we want to do that's not
the point what we're trying to find is a
way to bring some sustainability into
these systems in these deserts that are
really struggling so with the exception
of Anthem right now I don't have another
place to point to um and so we have to
you know there is certainly Sigma and
Harvard Pilgrim Pilgrim that we can talk
to that of private payers but Medicaid
doesn't provide any reimbursement for
this um and Medicare doesn't and so
these patients you know they're not
going to get a bill because there's you
know they're they're not getting bills
at least the ones that I know about and
there's no reimbursement for it except
that limited that one limited piece that
I've been able to carve out at this time
or or learn more
about representative Paz off and then
representative we can I can I just say
one more thing sure just to make sure I
tie this together thanks chair but if
they get transported and again shouldn't
be transporting people who don't want to
go or don't need to go okay then it's
then there is reimbursement that is
aligned in all of these situations it's
that other place so I think I left that
out and I wanted to make sure thank you
representative Palazo thank you and
thank you for taking my question so
different situation and uh fortunately
for me I don't have experience uh of
people dying in near me so I don't know
what happens but if a person passes away
is there still an opportunity for a
transportation do ambulances sometimes
transport corpses or is a total
Financial loss if a person pass
us thank you for the question so once um
they are deceased um I also had the
experience of being an associate Deputy
medical examiner so once they are
deceased um the really the funeral home
and once first of all the medical
examiner for covering for the county is
called to discuss the situation and to
decide whether they are um rule in for
an exam which includes a site visit
they're rule in for an exam and meaning
you would go do this and potentially to
go to an autopsy and you would have a
state pathologist on the phone to help
you make that decision in all of that
whatever gets decided whether they are
going or they are staying home and then
going to the funeral home that's when
The Possession takes place there
ambulances
don't they don't
transport um the they don't transport
the
deceased but I I have there have been
situations where due to location due to
weather due to difficulty the right
thing to do for the family and everybody
was to put them in the back of the
ambulance and to get them someplace else
but at that point when they are
considered their deceased by protocol
first it's to the medical County Medical
Examiner that's covering and then it's
the funeral
home okay representative
Weber so I'm interested in pursuing I
think repres representative tz's
question about costs and it's my
understanding
that in currently the only people who
are allowing some cost recovery is the
Anthem program that you were talking
about but when those costs are not
reimbursed am I correct in thinking that
the options are number one you send a
bill to the patient who can't pay it
because they're already on Medicaid or
uh or either the service in the case of
a private service or the taxpayers in
the case of a municipal or County
service are the people who are absorbing
those costs right
now thank you for the question
representative Weber I am unaware of any
services that are billing if they okay
go and they take care of somebody and
they don't transport them or they don't
for either they take care of them or
some situations it's just an assessment
like checking them up some it is that
and there is care um I'm unaware that
that happens but what I do know is that
because there is no reimbursement um and
again we know about this limit you know
we now are aware of Anthem um where
there's no reimbursement that means that
the cost shifting is clearly um to the
taxpayer and you know they want to have
these well-trained
professionals ready to go 247 but if you
know there's we could continue keeping
them well trained ready to go 247 by
providing some relief and so where other
states have turned to their State
Medicaid plan it made sense for us to
try to do this and follow up and when we
say it falls on the taxpayer we are
talking about the local property tax is
that correct in the city of Lebanon
where I live if the ambulance does not
you know they go and they do any take
care of any of those circumstances that
I talked about and they return back to
quarters you know that is part of what
we're paying for and if those so as a
final followup I promise I'll stop after
this one so if we were to adopt this we
would at least get ourselves to a place
where uh half of the cost would be paid
by general fund
taxpayers and half of it will be the the
dollars that we're already sending to
Washington DC and not getting all of
them back so we could get some more of
them back to pay for a service we're
rendering
here yes thank you other questions
representative
Palmer Dr hmer so my my concern and my
hope is that this would help the problem
that I see now which is quite frequently
we call for an ambulance transport say
from my hospital to Dartmouth and
there's there's a gap and it we
sometimes it can take 24 hours before we
can get transport obviously it depends
on the the patient what I'm hoping is
that if we get a little bit more money
and it's going to make it a little bit
more possible for
um to expand Services um so that's
that's my real concern because it's been
scary at times um and that's um and I
guess so that's one sort of question
about how you think how you think this
might help the other one is
um with the Medicare um should we be um
lobbying more on getting CMS to get
involved again and I'm going to
Washington in a month to do that with
that um is there any effort locally in
that direction that I should be aware of
before I go to Washington so thank you
representative Palmer so I'll work I'll
answer your question back back of work
in reverse order okay so I since et3 was
cancelled I have spoken with u Senator
Shaheen's office I have spoken with
Senator hasson's office and
representative kusters there was at
least one initiative to do a
demonstration program with some direct
funding that would have gone into West
Virginia you know West Virginia came
forward when et3 failed and said can we
try this pilot can we get some you know
Congressional direct dollars to do this
and that actually you know they
petitioned CMS was turned back um so I
would encourage you to continue this
conversation on Capitol Hill about the
situation with Emergency Medical
Services as a system of care that we
need to strengthen and this is one
really important part of it the second
piece has to do with uh what you're
seeing in emergency departments so some
of that is attributed to the fact that a
bed is occupied at where you want them
to go by the fact that they were trans
Ed because you know they were like okay
you know they decided to go but they
didn't really need to be there they
could have had this consultation they
could talk to medical control and
decided you know what I'm going to stay
home or I'm going to go to my primary
care provider or I'm going to go to
urgent care there's all of these avenues
that are now available to them but if
they get if they are transported to a
hospital that's a bed that is now not no
longer free for your patient from you
know say that you know Windsor County
Vermont to make the trip up to um you
know dartman health or wherever that
might be you know from the financial
side on the ambulance services piece it
anything that we can bring in this is
anything that we can continue to bring
in that makes their systems more
sustainable will improve the
availability of the workforce when I
first started doing this work and
actually it wasn't even when I first
started I worked in Northern New
Hampshire at ambulance services as a
paramedic I was paid $9 an hour okay now
that has gone up it's like maybe 20 $21
now it's still like there is um we don't
all do it for the money we love the work
but when you're deciding how to feed
your family and the career you need to
make of it and we're seeing these
shortages in healthare people are making
choices and so we're losing those folks
so I I hope that brought you where it is
but take it to Capitol Hill thank
you other
questions seeing on okay thank you very
much Senator thank you chairman Donald
good to see you all thank you for your
time
all right and all my stack of messy
right also signed up to speak is Michael
saitow from the New Hampshire
Association of Fire
Chiefs you've asked for two to four
minutes and I gu you have copies of
or good morning chairman thank you for
letting me speak on this matter I my
name is Mike setar I'm the fire chief of
the til Northfield bio District I run an
EMS service for Tilton and Northfield
and and mutual Aid Partners in the belac
and M County areas um I'm but I'm here
today representing the New Hampshire
Association of bioch Chiefs and
supported this legislation and it it it
seems fairly simple uh for people who
are
Medicaid um unfortunately they're in
that situation where they are onm
Medicaid and a lot of times the only way
they get medic Services by calling for
the ambulance because a lot of them
don't even have means to get
transportation to a hospital or another
provider even if they were able to do
that so they call for us for the
ambulance and mo a lot of times we can
treat them right on the spot for for
whatever malady they have without
transporting them to the hospital but if
we don't transport them to the hospital
we don't get any reimbursement for
Medicaid foot service so then we have to
so we do have to bring them to the
hospital if we want to get um paid for
it but many times it doesn't make any
sense for us to bring him to the
hospital so end up we end up just
treating them and the cost of that
treatment and for our availability is on
the local taxpayer we're just trying to
um offset some of our costs so the local
taxpayer is not absorbing the full cost
and as you all know we we do all pay off
federal taxes and it would be good to
have some of those tax dollars come back
and help support the local munit full
ambulance services um I have a you know
you can read my uh my letter and I don't
think it's it's late in the day in the
morning already and I be Happ to answer
any questions thank you
questions not seeing any okay thankk you
very
much also signed up to speak is Chris
dewi from the New Hampshire Ambulance
sir thank you my name is Chris dewas
from holls New Hampshire I a uh
celebrating my 40th year as a paramedic
uh this year and I represent the New
Hampshire Ambulance Association I won't
rehash everything that's already been
said but the Ambulance Association
supports this bill um to your point
representative Palmer about the
availability of services uh and how this
impacts that this is one piece of a
giant puzzle like a thousand piecer that
would take you forever to put together
um that will hopefully fill a gap for
reimbursement that will allow us as an
industry to provide more services to
people in a more timely fashion um the
unfortunate side of that is we seem to
be opposed by the insurance industry at
virtually every step of the way which
makes it even more difficult as we as an
industry are very small fish in a big
pond um so I I would ask this committee
to support this bill I would also be
more than happy to sit on any U work
group to look at ways that we can make
this bill better and Define it more
clearly that would still get it past the
Finish Line um and I'm happy to answer
any questions questions representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking this question
um I'm just curious um given that this
situation
I assume has been the the situation
um and there's so much interest in
making a change right now I'm just
interested in what what about the
current situation what about what in in
terms of the timing of the present
moment is this why is this coming to the
four right
now I think there's a variety of reasons
we like every other healthc care
provider in the industry have had a very
very difficult time with Recruitment and
Retention after covid um you see it
across Healthcare you see it across
Public Safety um we've certainly had a
very hard time with inflation um the
cost to uh ret re to train people
initially and then retain them with a
living wage is astronomically higher
than it was um and then the workforce
challenge of today's Generation Um you
know I have three young children in
their early 20s who uh don't want to
work overtime they want to leave at five
o'clock and in this industry that's not
possible um and in our industry in
particular I think as Senator Apprentice
mentioned um we have been underfunded
and underpaid and under um not able to
reimburse or pay people at a wage that
they deserve for the services that they
provide so I hate to use the analogy of
a perfect storm but a lot of things have
come together we've seen ambulance
services go out of business in New
Hampshire in a number of different
places and that puts pressure on the
entire system um we are a cog in a wheel
and if that Cog is missing the wheel
will not continue to turn in a in a
rapid fashion thank you very much
representative
Weber I was going to ask just as a
followup to that question hasn't there
also been an evolution over time where
um ambulance services used to be just
transport that's what they did and they
tried to keep people alive till they got
somebody else sure um and I'm aware that
in my town sometimes we transport and
meet another ambulance where there are
more highly trained people who take
people further on But as time has gone
on the people who arrive at your home
are more highly trained and more
qualified to provide initial assessment
and treatment which simply didn't happen
and I don't know how long ago it was
that it didn't happen but that's a real
evolution isn't it it is um you know
paramedics nowadays are practicing
medicine in people's homes and on the
scene and providing care that is akin to
what you would receive in the emergency
room um you know I I mentioned I've been
a paramedic for 30 or 40 years I should
say I was paramedic number 37 in this
state so uh you know and we weren't
doing a heck of a lot back then other
than uh compared to what we do now with
the amount of medications that are that
people are able to give and the amount
of diagnosis and advanced life support
treat that are out there so I think Co
brought out a lot of things that people
were unaware of that paramedics and EMTs
can do and how valuable they are to the
Health Care system as a an overall piece
of that
puzzle other questions representative
Palmer just going back to your comment
on opposition from insurance companies
so um I guess I'm trying to figure out
how much um I would think a lot of the
the non-transport patients or the
transport patients are are that tends to
skew towards the
Medicare bit um but I'm just trying to
get a if you have any sense of sort of
numbers of of transports or nonr any of
the idea of what the breakdown is
between private insurance and Medicare
Medicaid well you're correct Medicare
and Medicaid make up the line share of
most of the providers uh payer mix if
you will it's a about my understanding
is and depending upon where you are in
the state if you're in coldbrook it's
going to be different than if you're in
Portsmouth or or Keane um but the
commercial side of the insurance is
anywhere between 15 to 25% depending on
where you are and then you know there's
a difference in that commercial side of
orisa versus non-erisa you know
self-funded plans versus other
questions seeing done thank you thank
you
I have no one else signed up to testify
in this bill does anyone else wish to
testify Senate Bill
409 if not um representative Shapiro
indicates okay and on line six signed in
in support and no one signed in in
opposition so with that I'm going to
close the public hearing on Senate Bill
41 9 and open the public hearing on
Senate Bill 403 FN and Senator rosenal
her did she got me oh there she is okay
Senator
welcome
put your microphone on
please thank you Mr chairman good
morning members of the committee for the
record I'm Cindy rosenal and I represent
Senate District 13 in nashwa and I'm
thrilled actually to bring you Senate
Bill
403 this is a bill about build building
up the Future Health Care Workforce not
just retaining the workforce we have
which I think we all know is not really
adequate to meet the demands of our
aging
population and the lack of an adequate
Workforce has not only led to increased
costs in the system that providers have
had to pay
enormous temporary staffing costs but
there also indications that quality is
at risk for example the Kaiser
Foundation reports that the number of
hours of Care nursing home residents
received declined by
9% between 2015 and
2023 with nursing hours down a
staggering
21% so in addition to keeping the
workforce we have we have to take action
to make sure professionals can work at
the top of their scope and also we need
to interest students in health
careers this bill was um heavily amended
by the Senate and I don't know if you
have
the original fiscal note but if you do
please tear it
off um the one that said 32.1 million
yes tear that off okay and just deposit
it in a recycling bin
um what the bill basically does two
things now one it extends these repeal
date on the commission on the primary
care
Workforce um and
secondly it creates a process for
oplc to certify community health
workers community health workers and I
think there are some here today are not
clinical staff but there are people who
have the experience the culture and the
language of the community in which they
work they're
facilitators and they importance to the
broader Workforce is that they free up
the time of clinical licensed clinical
staff so those professionals can work at
the top of their
Scopes
certification of community health
workers will allow them to be reimbursed
by private insurance but also by
Medicaid the Department of Health and
Human Services believes they have enough
federal funds that they can use for the
reimbursement for the short term really
for the next fiscal year ongoing funding
would have to be considered within the
budget I'm happy to answer questions but
I know you've got a lot of pink
cards he thank you Senator uh questions
Senator
Rosenwald
okay apparently you covered it very well
oh thank you very much Mr chair thank
you
Senator and yes you're right we do have
a lot of pink
cards uh next up is uh Ben Bradley from
Association
thank you Mr chairman good morning
everybody once again my name is Ben
Bradley I'm the vice president of state
government relations for the New
Hampshire Hospital Association we
support s SP 403 relative to healthcare
Workforce Investments and although we
support all sections of s SP 403 I'd
like to focus on one section me
mentioned by uh Senator Rosen wal and
that's on community health workers um
hospitals and other health providers
employe community health workers would
not receive reimbursement for the
important Services they provide to
support patients in their ongoing care
and Recovery our members utilize this uh
community health workers to provide
patients with counseling and education
emotional support facilitation of Social
Services and health greeings among other
duties which I've outlined in my written
testimony um in a section here common
duties of a community health worker um
by passing s SP 403 the office of
professional ice Insurance certification
can promulgate rules uh as outlined by
Senator Rosen Wald to certify these
important workers um and help to
eliminate barriers uh that prevent
community health workers from seeking
reimbursement for their services
services that they provide please know
this is a really important bill not just
to hospitals uh which I speak for but so
many others and I want to thank Senator
Rosen wal for her commitment to seeing
this through um happy to answer any
questions uh and look forward to working
with you all okay thank you any
questions from Mr Bradley yes
representative palazov thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question would it be correct assumption
that community health workers it's less
expensive to hire them than other
licensed medical Prof profal um to be
completely honest I don't know the
answer to that um if I was to assume I
would say yes um but there may be others
behind me that could answer that
question for
you other
questions saying none thank you thanks
Mr
chairman also signed up to speak is
Christa Morris from the Department of
Health and Human Services and I I will
remind people that other than the time
sponsor we do try to keep testimony to
three minutes and give them the volume
of cards we have please try to do that
thank
you good morning my name is Christa
Morris I'm the director of
intergovernmental affairs with DHHS and
basically I just want to say that we are
here in support of the bill as it stands
uh and really we're here to answer any
questions that you may have I just put
on the card as needed so any questions
that was a
question um representative Shapero thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
this question I'm not sure you're the
right person to direct it to I will try
page one I guess
um line 22 where it talks about the
nurse Practice Act and the change that's
being made it seems to me that it's um
adding um letter B has been employed as
a LNA for at least one year so do I am I
assuming correctly that that is raising
the standard of who can um administer
true okay uh someone else is here to
testify on that part okay thank you very
much other
questions seeing none thank
you
also signed up to speak is weska
Castillo from the city of Nashville
Public
Health and thank you you've only asked
that thank you again my name is graa
Castillo I am here on behalf of Public
Health for the city of
nsha I am currently a community health
worker I am one voice speaking to you
all today but I am here on behalf of
many community health workers I am in
support of this bill as a community
health worker my professional
development started in
2015 um mainly in clinical settings and
Hospital settings I have worked
alongside many
professionals I've gained my trainings
and um education through these
professionals certification is important
to us like many have saying many have
said to sustain the
workforce working starting work in 2016
I saw that funding came and went my work
wasn't sustained by the funding that was
uh being provided my positions have
changed um
in various um years um but my passion
for um providing Community Health work
to the community I serve I am bilingual
I did come from I am Hispanic background
um coming from a family that um where
there was only one adult who spoke
English um that baton was passed to me
at the early age of 12 so I consider
myself to be a community health worker
since then
um this is what I love to do my
accreditation right now is the words of
um my peers that I help in the community
um um the community I serve and the
outcomes um that those things provide um
like I
said certification is important and um
sustainability for us to continue to do
the things we' love to do for our
community that's it thank you very much
you
guys thank you any
questions seeing none thank you very
you also signed up to speak is former
Senator Peggy Gilmore representing the
greater Nash Chamber of
minutes thank you Mr chair with your
permission I've brought
um a better expert uh Wendy hunt who is
the uh CEO of the greater National
Chamber of Commerce if she may and she's
here to tell you why the business
Community is in such support of Senate
Bill 403 thank
you good
morning good morning thank you uh
chairman McDonald for hearing me and to
fellow committee members um as Peggy
said I'm Wendy hunt I'm president the
CEO of of the greater National chamber
we represent over 440 business members
large small private nonprofit of all
sectors including manufacturing retail
Hospitality Health Care education so
forth as well as the thousands of
residents they employ the city of
Nashville is the second largest
population in the state and is home to
some of the state's largest hospitals St
Joe's Southern New Hampshire healthc
care providers such as Dartmouth health
lrey health the greater National Mental
Health Center Harbor care obviously you
Des heard um from um the the uh public
um Health Care addiction mental health
veterans homeless Outreach and more the
chamber consistently hears from our
healthc care members that Staffing
shortages in all departments are at a
critical point and they are in desperate
need of help from Business Leaders and
our state legislators to help them find
a solution to develop a health care
pipeline of Talent on behalf of the
chamber Healthcare Community I'm here to
support s SP 403 which would to help
address the state's critical Healthcare
Workforce shortages I can give you a
number of reasons but I know we're
limited on time um let's just say this
is impacting all of business across the
state um I'm not speaking for everyone I
am speaking for the businesses that we
represent and happy to take any
questions I also have copies for you
okay thank you very much representative
palaza thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question I wonder about
fees uh my my understanding that uh
community health workers would need to
pay uh by annually some fee do have any
idea like um if it will be an issue for
them and if businesses uh um sometimes
certification I'm really not do you know
P not an expert on that
sorry I think there are people behind
who will address that but certainly
often representative uh an employer or
potential employer will pay a fee in
depending on the case but but ask
questions seeing none okay thank you
very
much also signed up to
speak
CIS I can't quite make out all the
initials you've thrown down here so I
I'll let you address
yes thank you Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Alex Kris I'm here to
represent the long-term care Community
specifically uh New Hampshire
Association of Residential Care Homes
and the New Hampshire healthc care
Association which is the association of
the private nursing
homes we do support the entire uh piece
of
legislation and I won't belabor because
I think this committee's heard a lot
over the last year and a half about the
healthcare Workforce crisis in the State
and this bill is a obviously a response
to that we do have a specific section of
the bill that was requested by the um
the private nursing homes and that's
section
four and to answer representative
Shapiro's
question uh so the
current uh Board of Nursing regulations
require in order to be a medication
nursing assistant or an m& you have to
have been a practicing LNA licensed
nursing assistant for two full years so
this uh Amendment to the nurse Practice
Act would cut in half the two-year
requirement that's currently in
administrative rules obviously as you
know as legislators uh law Will trump
those rules so this really is a
obviously you remember the the kma bill
that you uh were very kind enough to
have that special public hearing and we
were able to work with all the
stakeholders so I see see this as as
really a companion piece to that you
heard that there's Sarah NATO who spoke
to this committee many times uh you know
her facility doesn't have lnas so that's
why we have the kma as a as an option
for particularly some of those smaller
assisted living homes for facilities and
it could be a home health it could be a
nursing home it could be a larger
assisted living facility that employ
lnas under this they would be able to
send lnas that are in their employe to
the m&a class
once they've been in LNA for one full
year so this doesn't cost any money to
do this it's just uh removing an
administrative barrier I I certainly
wouldn't want to speak for the oplc but
I did check with Lindsay Courtney who's
the executive director and she did tell
me that she was supportive of this
change and uh they don't have any
concerns from the the licensing uh state
agency that would that would implement
this so it would go eff would go
effective upon passage and as I said
it's a I think it's a common sense um
Workforce barrier that we're going to
reduce and again it doesn't cost any any
dollars and the regulatory body uh is in
favor of it so I I hope that you will
retain it in the bill as the Senate has
done so thank you very much thank you
any questions representative
n a do thank you for allowing me to ask
a question thank you for taking my
question um would an medical nursing
assistant earn a little bit more than
just a
regular and here you repr representative
oh um would um it's Mna m& would they
earn a little bit more money per hour
than I mean LNA they would they would
have a higher level of training they
would be more valuable to the agency I I
can get you some numbers in terms of um
I I think that I have figures that show
the average wage of the of an LNA and M
that would be interesting and the m&a is
a little bit higher so but certainly
incentivizing for lnas to have another
step to move up quickly and help with
our Healthcare needs thank you yes they
would be more versatile in the facility
they'd be able to obviously discharge
more duties and also relieve the nurses
so they can focus on on larger Health
Care issues so it it's a it's continu
minim of care U so again I think all the
stakeholders are in favor of this we we
heard no opposition and it's a really a
modest step and a companion to the piece
of legislation that you already already
welcome also signed up to speak is
Christine stardard from by state Primary
Care
Association yeah well most most of the
people who uh signed up are from
different organizations there is one
person from the public um Paul friedrick
from
exor
you've asked two minutes sir yeah thank
you I'll be brief uh Paul friedricks I'm
a retired family physician from exiter
spent 35 years uh working in a nonprofit
Community Health Center in arachim
County I want to make two points first
is in the course of my career it's it
became more and more obvious to myself
and the medical profession that the
social determinants of Health are
critical to uh uh our health in the
community and to Health Care
expenditures
um what you need food you need housing
you look need to look for insurance
Transportation coordinating of your
services the second point I make is that
in my 35- year career I I had the
benefit of working with community health
centers community health workers excuse
me uh so I'm very much in favor of the
process for them to be certified and
then to progress to enhance their
professional uh ability to work in the
system and seek reimbursement from
insurers um family doctors have a lot to
do per care physicians have a lot to do
we need help uh and community health
workers can step up and provide th that
help address the social determinance of
Health that is critical to our patients
and make a big difference and in the
long run save a lot of money by helping
us keep people out of emergency rooms
out of in their own homes out of the
hospital out of nursing facilities so
it's a slam dunk as far as I'm concerned
thank you for listening to me any
question are you taking any questions
sir I don't if we have any a
representative pmer thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking the question
um I was also in Primary Care before I
became a hospitalist and I wonder if you
had the same experience with community
health workers which I found a godsend
when we had them but we kept having we
get a grant and we'd have them and then
we'd lose the Grant and they would go
away yeah and so I mean
well that that's why this certification
process is here to make them more
sustainable and it sounds like we have
people like the women who spoke earlier
who are happy to do their careers and
very interested in doing that highly
motivated uh individuals serving in
these positions I had the benefit of
serving in a federally qualified
Community Health Center so we had more
consistent
funding but yeah represented palazov
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question I wonder what will
happen to a community health worker if
they fail to pass
certification uh I have full confidence
that the individuals that I worked with
community health workers would have no
trouble they've committed time years in
their lives often uh and are highly
motivated uh I don't see it as being an
extremely um you know high-end test that
they'd have to take it would be showing
that they have skills they have
amplitude uh and uh interest so I I'm
not too concerned about that okay other
you also signed up to speak is Paula
Smith from Southern New Hampshire
minutes
good morning um my name is Paula Smith
and I work at the southern New Hampshire
area health education center we say ahac
I've been there for the past 26 years
I'm also a member of the New Hampshire
chw Coalition I've been working on
issues related to community health
workers here in New Hampshire since
2005 so I'm here to really encourage you
to invest in the New Hampshire
Healthcare Workforce care deeply about
all pipeline um but today I just want to
talk about um as people have said
community health workers are key members
of The healthc Care team they act as the
bridge between the community and the
Health Care System including Behavioral
Health and oral health as well chws are
trusted members of the community who
help people with the non-medical aspects
of their lives as Dr Friedrich said the
social determinants of Health are key to
our health 80% of our well-being is a
result of where we live work and play
while only 20% is dependent on the
health care that we actually
receive currently chws are supported
primarily by
grants and chw certification will assure
that we can find ways to reimburse them
for their services and sustain this
crucial member of the workforce we
recently conducted a survey of community
health workers using using nationally
recognized indicators called the chw
common indicators project highlights of
this report show that 58% of community
health workers in New Hampshire work in
community based organizations Family
Resource Centers schools insurance
providers and local Health departments
42% work in clinical settings such as
hospitals and federally qualified health
centers chws are most likely to provide
care coordination and system navigation
r gos as well as advocating on behalf of
individuals and communities 78% of the
chws report working with people
experiencing homelessness substance use
disorders or people with disabilities
and some work with all three groups so
we have been asking over the past year
to have chws share their stories so you
could really learn about what they do in
the
community one chw shared a story with me
about helping a person who is living in
a van
the person helped the person get glasses
which allowed him to get a job he was
then able to get an apartment on his own
so helping to build an individual's
capacity to care for themselves is a
fundamental part of the chw role other
themes that emerg from the stories
include helping people manage their
chronic illness connecting people to
needed resources and providing linkages
to organizations that can meet their
health and Behavioral Health needs
support of this bill will help New
Hampshire care for the people living
here thank you thank you perfect timing
any questions representative Shapiro and
then representative Canon thank you Mr
chairman and um thank you for taking the
question there been a good deal of
discussion about among other things
about reimbursement for these Services
once someone is certified and I see at
the very end of the bill talks about
Medicaid applying for a uh a Medicaid
State Plan Amendment a Medicaid State
Plan Amendment thank you um and so my
question really is have those been
requested in other states and approved
in other states yes absolutely and it's
part of the New Hampshire chw Coalition
we have a certification committee which
is working on drafting rules that we can
work with oplc to do um and thinking
about other ways of you know looking
part of our research was looking at what
other states have done um including um
you know exploring
The Physician fee schedule for Medicare
the state plan Amendment and working
with other um insurance companies to see
if we can get help to cover the
cost so do you have an idea of how many
other states have have
um received approval for reimburse
reimbursing community health workers I
don't have that information on the top
of my tongue but I could find that for
you okay thank you very much other
questions
you also signed up to speak is Kylie
Hughes from Southern New Hampshire area
health education
minutes hello my name is Carly Hughes
and I'm a community health worker I've
had I now held two roles as Community
Health worker in my first role at a
feder qualified Health Center I work
directly with patients in the primary
care settings as well as in the
community in the community I was able to
meet people in their own space and
discuss how to access medical care and
how to overcome barriers in this role I
also became certified to become a health
coach as a health coach I would meet
with patients that had chronic illnesses
one woman I worked with was living with
high blood pressure high cholesterol and
obesity working with her was wonderful
we met bi-weekly and through the use of
motivational interview were able to set
obtainable goals making small changes
weekly throughout our sessions she was
able to make major life changes become
healthy and more active than she had
been in a long time this woman looked
forward to spending time with her
daughter outside again and was able to
regain access to some wonderful parts of
the life her life that she had been
missing I also had the privilege to work
in a mobile healthc care setting
bringing the care to the community and
spaces where it was needed along with
providing Medical Care to our patients
through our providers were able to
assist in accessing resources and ways
to have their needs
met I also got to spend time working in
Reverse Primary Healthcare integration
programs Primary Care within the
community health care center here I was
able to work closely with a population
that statistically does not receive the
health care they require and often die
25 years earlier on average than those
outside of the mental health care System
well in this setting I was working with
one woman in particular that had
extremely high anxiety she needed
routine Medical Care and that was hard
for her
often time patients are given referrals
to obtain care with a
specialist and as I'm sure you all know
this can be difficult you get a referral
and then that place doesn't take your
insurance or you need an immediate
appointment and they give you one that's
six months out this is challenging for
anyone and then when you have a patient
who's already struggling with navigating
the healthare system has had experiences
that may not been the best in the past
I'm happy to be there I'm happy to be
able to
help
I work working with this individual I
made sure she not only had everything
she needed but I was also able to put
the pieces together for her with that
support she attended her appointment and
got the care that she needed I think
it's important to remember that we are
here to help the community members
attend to the things they need to do we
are not enabling people to become
dependent on a system instead we are
giving every interaction the best chance
to become successful we are here to
cheer them on and then to navigate the
barriers when they arise in my current
position I am what I like to recer to as
a community health worker for community
health workers I'm a program coordinator
I assist in facilitating Community
Health worker training that is offered
by my organization I truly love seeing
the growth during a class and I'm
looking forward to continuing to be a
resource for all community health
workers community health workers are
doing great work there are many spaces
not only in healthcare but mental health
Family Resource Centers schools and more
where chw integration has yet to start
obtaining Community Health worker
certification will help sustain the
current Workforce and continue to Pro
provide our communities with the support
they need our communities need our help
and we want to be here to close the
gaps thank you representative Shapero
thank you Mr chairman I I wonder in your
um role as a community health worker or
now is in supporting other community
health workers how will this change
you're already doing it so how will this
change this added
certification enrich your experience as
a worker I when I say enrich I don't
expect you to get rich but um um but how
will it how will it change either
materially or otherwise your situation I
feel that the um the workforce will be
able to expand we'll be able to you know
I I I work with a lot of people who are
community health workers and there it's
Grant funded so they don't know what's
happening at the end of this grant they
don't know how long the work is going to
be sustained so being able to be
comfortable in your position and
continue working for it I think is going
to be huge for the position thank you
representative pazo thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
uh I'm trying to look uh
into some uh additional load on
community health workers so obviously
they would need to pay by annual fee but
also page four uh lines 31 and 32 talks
about any rules promulgated by the
executive director so we will have new
Administration above you
promulgating additional rules on you
maybe additional paperwork so I wonder
how it affects the amount of work you
will be able to do besides following
asking so I just want
if we create this new Administration
above you and they will require you to
spend time for certification to pay fees
for certifications to follow some
additional rules and paperwork that it
will take from your ability to provide
actual
work um I don't foresee it being a ton
and in my position where I support other
community health workers I will I plan
to be a available to help them with any
of that that they may that they may need
um I don't I see it helping us sustain
the workforce more than preventing us
from continuing what we're
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank
you also signed up to speak is Patricia
gas glass stter from the city of Nashua
Public Health
Department
did I pronounce that correctly glass you
did very well asked for two minutes
thank you very much good morning and
thank you for this opportunity to speak
in support of Senate Bill 403 and
specifically to the
certification and investment into our
community health
workers I my name is Patricia glastad
I'm a public health nurse at the city of
NASA Public Health Department greska
behind me that spoke earlier she and I
are
co-workers um so I am very much in
supported that portion of the
bill our Public Health Team Works in
collaboration with our Community
Partners including nonprofits Health
Care Systems private organizations and
government agencies to deliver Services
throughout the 13 cities and towns in
the greater naal Public Health Region
it's a very large
area without adequate funding for the
health care Workforce including our
community health workers we risk a weak
a weakened defense against outbreaks
slow response times to health
emergencies and diminished Community
Health
Services this shortfall could lead to
increased disease transmission
heightened Health disparities and a
strain on Health Care Systems ultimately
compromising the overall well-being of
our New Hampshire
residents enclosing in our health care
and public health Workforce to measure
to prevent these potential consequences
supporting Senate Bill 403 is an
essential step to safeguarding the
health of our New Hampshire communities
I thank you all for listening um and
your considerations to this portion of
the bill thank you any
questions say nothing thank you very
much also signed up to speak is Bobby
Bagley from also from the division of
Public Health in the city of nashal
minutes
good morning and thank you my name is
Bobby Bagley and I am the chief Public
Health official for the city of
Nashville's division of Public Health
and community services and I um actually
have a team of community health workers
that are working out of our health
department I am in support of Senate
Bill uh 403 for the very reason that the
work that the community health workers
does touches so many lives not just the
individuals that they serve but they're
also in support of the partner
organizations that we work with they are
the Liaisons between the community and
between the organizations as well um and
I'll just tell you a quick little story
so we have uh the opportunity they're
the boots on the ground and so they are
the ones that have that extended hand or
provide that soft handoff between the uh
organizations that might be providing
services to the community themselves so
we have one individual that one of our
community health workers uh met during
uh Outreach who was living in the tent
uh was able to connect with this
individual build trust with this
individual they had been living outside
for eight years also was able to build a
relationship with a landlord and was
able to get this individual housed in an
apartment uh this was an individual who
had um issues with substance use
disorder but was in recovery and in
order to sustain recovery you need to
have housing you need to be able to not
think about things that are going to
cause barriers for you so the community
health worker as liaison between this
individual and this landlord was able to
get this person housed and one of the
things that this individual shared with
us was they are in a better position now
because they'd rather spend their money
on paying for supporting their housing
needs than paying for substances so they
play a very important role in helping
with the social determinance of Health
as you've heard the community health
workers are there to make phone calls
they've helped people get their driver's
licenses they've helped them get their
um ID so that they could get jobs
they're also helping individuals get
employment so this Workforce has been uh
substantial for us and as gresa has has
U mentioned they love the work that they
do the certification will allow for us
to maintain sustainability of this
Workforce you've also heard about we
have these um individuals in place
because of Grants the grants come and go
at the beginning of this year in January
I had to start telling my team I may not
have funding for you in six months so
that's that's disruptive for them and
then one of the first questions they
asked was what's going to happen to all
the people that we now made contact with
if we're not here to help them continue
on their Journeys either in recovery
preventing evictions reducing emergency
room visits or just making contact with
people to reduce social isolation so I
stand very firmly in support of this
certification um for the community
health worker um and Senate Bill uh 403
and I hope that you will as well thank
you thank you any
questions seeing done okay thank you
thank
you and now Christine started you my
last print card do you want to testify
by state Primary Care
Association thank you and good morning
um as a chair said my name is Christine
Stoddard and I work for bate Primary
Care Association we represent New
Hampshire's community health centers
which serve over 100 th000 patients and
many of them children and we also work
with the area health education centers
um like Paula mentioned earlier I want
to stress that um our by state and our
members are very much in support of this
bill but what's important to remember
about the community health worker piece
is that it's voluntary
certification so we worked very closely
with the chw community to draft this
legislation um and of course with
Senator Rosenwald because not every
organization that um has chws takes
Medicaid or accepts commercial insurance
so we want to make sure that we don't
harm chws who are currently working with
organizations that might not accept
insurance so it it is completely
voluntary and so if an organization
accepts Medicaid after the state plan
amendment is approved by CMS they will
be able to build Medicaid for those chw
Services which will then sustain that
Workforce and
almost all of our um community health
centers employ chws the ones that don't
the main reason is because of a lack of
sustainability they too were in the
position earlier this year when they had
to notify their chws that there might
not be um grant funding available in six
months and thankfully DHHS was able to
find additional funding to support that
work but had they not those chws would
have been out of um would have likely
lost their jobs and they placed such an
integral role in people accessing
Community Health Services um that it it
would have really harmed the communities
that you represent in New Hampshire um
I'm happy to answer any questions if you
questions representative
Weber this is cheating but would you
believe I just would really like to
thank everybody who's come here today
for the work that they're doing I Su
others on the committee do as well thank
you
absolutely representative
pmer this is a little bit a little bit
like would you believe too but I I don't
know if you have any sense it an example
I would give of what's what I've seen it
where I've seen Community Health worker
really be helpful is I sent somebody
home from the hospital and the community
health care worker goes out there the
next day and finds out that well they
didn't pick up the prescription for
their diuretic that was what got them
into the hospital in the first place
because they either couldn't get there
or they didn't have the money and the
community healthcare
worker does that gets that job yes and
so my question is so on the one hand we
may be spending a little bit more money
to pay for the community healthcare
workers through Medicaid but I would
imagine we are going to Save A Lot in
both you know both human suffering not
ending up in the ER again but also not
another hospitalization yes
representative Palmer that's a really
good point Coos County family health
services which is located in Berlin and
Gorham they have a large number of
patients who are Homebound and so the
community health workers can go out and
check on those patients and make sure
that they don't have rugs in the way
that they could trip on um that if they
need utility assistance they can connect
them with utility assistance many of our
chws Al also work to um find housing
supports and also Mortgage Assistance U
during the pandemic so they really are
um going out into the communities
members of the communities and they can
connect people with Services if they
need them and and honestly some patients
don't know that those Services exist um
until they're told by a
chw representative Plaza thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question I I don't know if you are right
qu right person to ask this question but
maybe you were at previous hearings on
this bill so B what what will be the
side of administration to manage this
program I see there will be an executive
director but also in fiscal note it
talks about eight paid positions
but Senator said that U that fiscal note
might be outdated after the amendment so
yes um the fiscal note is is outdated so
those were relating to appropriation
sections that were removed by the Senate
and the executive director position
that's mentioned in that chw language is
actually the director of oplc so we will
work with oplc to draft the rules um for
the chws and it was written that way so
that we don't create additional
administrative burden for the State of
New Hampshire and it was modeled after
the opic dispensers um which already
exist other questions
you uh no one else has signed up to
testify I have no other pink cards does
anyone else wish to
testify representative Shapiro could you
tell me what the oh represent M D or one
of
against noon okay representative Lon
online there's 49 in support and one
opposed wow
okay okay uh with that that is the last
public hearing we have scheduled for
this morning we have one um we resume at
1 o'clock this
afternoon uh so we're going to uh recess
you
e
good afternoon everyone and welcome back
to the house committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs we
have three more bills to hear this
afternoon and the first one is number
456 Senator Ganon is the prime sponsor
but he's over with the state house right
now and and I just left there and
there's a power short power outage over
there everything's in dark darkness so
so um I had I had to foro my tuna melt
as a result of that I want you to know
but fortunately I did get some hot soup
so at least got that uh so in Senator
ganon's place we once again have Grant
bosy the Deputy Chief of Staff of the
Senate do I have your title right that
is correct okay well welcome back thank
you Mr chairman it's good to be back
before the house uh Health and Human
Services committee my name is Grant
bossy Deputy Chief of Staff of the New
Hampshire Senate here with the um thanks
of Senator Bill Ganon for your courtesy
uh as you may know Senator Ganon uh was
in the hospital for six weeks last year
he's been a lot and he's a talkative guy
so he had a number of conversations with
uh the nurses that took such good care
of him and he said well what can we do
in the legislature to make your life a
little easier uh and the answer he kept
getting was help us with the student
loans um as you know we have a healthare
worker shortage in New Hampshire we are
having a hard time uh at all levels of
New Hampshire's healthc care system
finding and retaining uh trained healthc
Care Professionals such as uh registered
nurses and other nursing professionals
uh senator Ganon brought in uh SP 456 to
try to address this Workforce shortage
uh as a way to provide benefits to
nurses particularly at the beginning of
their career paying off their student
loans uh he believes that uh this sort
of incentive program will become a
magnet to bring uh just graduated
nursing students to New Hampshire
hospitals and Healthcare facilities and
to keep them here as they start their
career and start their families the bill
is amended by the Senate would add
$300,000 uh to the Department of Human
Services State Office of rural Health uh
for a dedicated non-aps fund uh under
the student loan repayment program it
also directs DHHS to uh report to the
legislature on ways to cover uh nurses
that might not qualify for this uh
current program uh to make sure that
we're addressing everybody that we might
want to uh get here uh I would defer
technical questions to the department to
some of the healthcare uh a uh groups
that are here uh behind me but if you've
got any questions for G Senator Ganon
specifically I can make sure to get you
an
answer
okay representative Shapero thank you Mr
chairman I'm not sure if this is a
technical question or not um but feel
free to wave it off um so I know there's
a
uh currently a program for healthcare
workers in general I think it's called
the slurp program and I guess I'm
wondering why having a why having a
different separate program specifically
for nurses May if there is a is it just
kind of to add more to what we can do or
is there a specific reason um why we're
creating another program for one group
of people that's an excellent question
it's one that the Senate Health and
Human Services committee also asked
Senator Ganon he had set it up uh
originally as introduced as a separate
program and what they decided to do was
work it into the sort program but that's
that's concentrating on Rural health so
there might not be um it might not cover
all facilities uh that might not qualify
as rural under the student loan
repayment program um and that's why we
have the reporting requirement to say
okay we're we're putting $300,000 in
there let's get this going a little
boost to nurses through the current
pipeline but if it's not covering
anybody come tell us what we can do to
make sure it's covering everybody we
need to so yeah the the senate in its
Amendment put it through the slurp
program uh rather than a separate
pipeline thank you very much other
questions representative
Palazo thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question I'm just
trying to figure out the numbers so the
bill talks about a appropriation of
300,000 and
then Ann all cost is listed as uh over
17 million per per year so I'm trying to
figure out what we are actually doing
like how much we are spending
additionally with this bill uh it is
amended to a one-time non-aps $300,000
appropriation that's the price tag
that's the total cost the fiscal note
that's attached to the bill as as it was
introduced so that is no longer
applicable that that's how the program
was introduced as amended it's a onetime
$300,000 appropriation representative
who you wanted to add to that or no
that's exactly
okay just just for anybody's information
they always come with a fiscal note that
was
drafted when the bill was submitted and
sometimes we get extras we got three or
four new redrafted fiscal notes to today
but what's attached to the bill is often
no longer what the cost is and this is a
clear one time 300,000 if I'm not
mistaken yeah that's correct if you'd
like LBA I'm sure they could produce an
updated fiscal note to you but in this
case the bill it's two paragraphs
there's a number in it's not as needed
it's a it's very clear in the bill text
itself that it's $300,000 it's one time
it's
non-aps thank you other
you and Mr chairman yes representative
Weber could I just ask if somebody down
by the door might close it just because
the comings and goings is sure in the
hall Mr Mr Boss he s sh up could you
close the door for us thank you I
appreciate
it also signed up to speak is Sean
Jackson and Danielle Hernandez from the
Department of Health and Human
Services
and you've asked for three minutes so
when you're whenever you're ready don't
on good afternoon chair uh members of
the committee thank you for your time
today uh the
my name is Sean Jackson I am the section
administrator for the rural health and
Primary Care section at New Hampshire's
dep Department of Health and Human
Services Division of Public Health
Services Danielle Hernandez I'm the
Health Professions data center
administrator under rural health and
primary
care so thank you Mr chair uh we are
here today the department is here today
in support of Senate Bill 456 as amended
uh we we worked closely with Senator
Ganon on the amendment for this bill
when it was in the Senate and the Senate
saw fit to to pass it as amended um what
this program does as was articulated by
Senator Ganon staff member um is that
this is a one-time $300,000
appropriation to slurp State loan
repayment program uh which is tasked of
the mission of the state loan repayment
program is to help to recruit and retain
qualified caregivers into our Rural and
medically underserved areas of the State
uh that are designated as such by the
federal government um this bill Pro uh
proposes two Provisions as we spoke
about uh it appropriates $300,000 to the
state laan repayment program uh for
specific use of those that are licensed
under the nurse practice act so
registered nurses uh advanced practice
registered nurses and psychiatric nurse
practitioners are the current eligible
uh nursing professions for the state
loan repayment program as was
articulated earlier this is not in
addition to the state loan repayment
program this has been uh as amended has
been integrated into the state loan
repayment program with the current
policies and the current guidelines uh
that that govern that particular program
uh the other piece that this bill would
do is is to uh direct the department to
establish a budget to establish a a
separate program specific for nurses um
both of those uh we are in support of as
I said the current state Lo repayment
program is intended to incentivize the
Recruitment and Retention of qualified
caregivers uh to our most vulnerable
residents in our Rural and our medically
underserved areas um as of right now we
have 100 active contracts uh under the
state loan repayment program the general
funds that fund this program um are set
to be expended we are are obligated for
all of the monies that the general fund
has has um saw fit to appropriate to the
program uh therefore uh we would be in a
position of needing to put applicants on
a wait list uh moving forward without
this uh without this appropriate ation
um some of the things that this bill
will do the
$300,000 um will fully fund six to1
full-time contracts with nursing PR uh
nursing professionals into again our
Rural and underserved areas um over the
course of a three-year contract so these
contracts are uh three years long for a
full-time commitment or two years long
for part-time service in a rural or
underserved area um on the threeyear
contracts depending upon the the tier so
Physicians and dentists receive the top
tier because they tend to have the
highest loan burden that they carry um
and then
$45,000 over the course of a a threeyear
commitment for full-time uh nurse
practitioners and then $30,000 a year uh
$30,000 over the course of a three-year
contract for registered nurses working
in primary care so six to 10 full-time
contracts given the average patient load
that a a medical professional will see
of about three patients per hour over
the course of a three-year full-time
contract this single appropriation has
has an impact on over 15,000 patients in
areas uh thank you for the opportunity
to provide testimony happy to answer any
you also signed up to
speak is Ben Bradley from the New
Association
thanks Mr chairman I think this is my
final appearance today before the
committee um two more bills just as a
reminder uh my name is Ben Bradley I'm
the vice president of state government
relations for the New Hampshire Hospital
Association um we support uh SV 456 and
our members deeply appreciate the
support from the sponsors of this
legislation um healthc care careers are
often a calling and qualified engaged
diverse Workforce is at the heart of New
Hampshire's Healthcare System uh it's no
secret that hospitals have been facing
significant challenges that make it
difficult to uh sustain build and retain
a strong Healthcare Workforce um we did
a recent vacancy report uh most recently
2022 actually um and in that report we
had an 18% vacancy rate for uh nurses
specifically um we appreciate the
support uh and and support the continued
efforts of State leaders and our federal
delegation to increase enrollment at
nursing programs uh at New Hampshire
colleges and universities passing s SP
456 would ensure the Investments to in
educating nursing students in New
Hampshire aren't lost on other states uh
aren't lost to other states attracting
nursing graduates with robust student
loan repayment incentives um s SP 456
provides a modest appropriation for the
existing State student loan repayment
program to attract and retain um retain
nursing Workforce in New Hampshire uh
according to the American Association of
colleges of nurses of nursing the median
amount of student loan debt anticipated
by graduate nursing students upon
completion of their program was between
40,000 and just under um
$55,000 We Believe student loan
repayment is an important tool that can
make the difference in a nurse's
decision to work in New Hampshire um we
also support the provisions that
instruct the department to provide a
report to the legislature on a budget
proposal for a student loan forgiveness
program that could extend beyond just
the
slrp um we think this would be an
important reference for Budget
considerations in the next bium um
thanks for your time I'm happy to answer
your questions thank you oh I have WR
testimony too okay thank
thank you thank you
Mr also signed up to
speak is Christine started from by state
Primary Care
Association once I again you the last
one I'll take that as a compliment well
um I think in the Bible they said he was
she who's first will be last or
something like
that thank you good afternoon my name is
Christine Stoddard and I represent by
state Primary Care Association and New
Hampshire's community health centers um
our community health centers rely
heavily on the state loan repayment
program to recruit and retain qualified
Health Care Professionals it is often
times the one thing that gets a healthc
care professional to commit to working
at a ferally qualified Health Center
they are located um as Sean said in
medically underserved areas and often
times rural areas is one of our health
centers serves five different
communities um people travel great
length to work at these facilities and
it is hard to recruit people um to work
in Northern New Hampshire depending on
what the opportunities are for their
spouses or partners and the state loan
repayment program provides a carrot to
get people in the door and keep them
there um our health centers would love
to see additional funding to the state
loan repayment program as many of you
know federal student loans were paused
during the pandemic and they were turned
back on last fall and in
2019 um the legislature approved a
budget that included $6 A5 million do
for the state loan repayment program um
much of that funding was used for the
state's pandemic response but the state
did retain o over $4 million for slurp
and that money as Sean mentioned is now
gone and so that demonstrates the need
for the state loan repayment program and
how much we rely on it and the bill that
you heard earlier today um was
introduced with a significant
appropriation to the state owner payment
program and we would love for that to
happen I realize that's not included in
this bill but um any anything that you
can do and to support the state loan
repayment program is greatly appreciated
because it is such an important tool for
our um Health Centers to use I'm happy
questions none okay thank
you no one else has signed up to testify
on um SP 456 FN does anyone else wish to
testify representative Shapiro can you
online
yes okay thank you and online seven
signed in and support and one an
opposition okay thank you all right if
no one else wishes to testify I'm going
to close the public hearing on sp sp 456
FN uh the next hearing is going to be at
1:30 so we're going to be in a brief
recess until then which time we'll hear
FN
Erica yeah is it that one person when I
was I haven't looked these ones up but
last time I looked online there was one
opposition
e
good afternoon Mr chair and good
afternoon to all of the committee
members as well thank you so much for um
hearing me today my name is Shannon
chandley and um I have the honor of
serving the people of Milford marac
Amherst and Wilton District 11 in the
state senate um I come before you today
to introduce SB
496 um
which is a um um it directs the
Department of Health and Human Services
to Monitor and respond to harmful
impacts of um the climate and weather
and the environment on mental and
physical health um as we all know New
Hampshire is experiencing changing
weather um sometimes with extreme
weather events I think that this week is
a terrific time for me to be introducing
it because as we know we had quite the
snow storm St last Thursday um there
were a number of effects from that storm
on our um electric and so forth but
there are also um effects on our envir
the environment around us from um these
changes in weather and some of the Very
extreme conditions that occur um these
might include longer growing Seasons
later Fall Foliage intense heat waves
rainstorms flooding wildfire s and air
quality issues also that then affects um
the the changes in the climate will
affect uh not just uh human beings but
the uh whe what kinds of um insects or
um it it has an effect on our wildlife
and what our exposure is to potential
diseases that uh maybe uh insect born um
the the challenge
the environmental changes are
challenging and I think that there are a
number of ways we in the state are
trying to innovate in order to deal with
the uh being prepared for the changes
but also we are concerned about any
harmful Health impacts um this bill
would establish a position that already
existed at one time at DHHS it was a
grant-funded position um and and it when
the grant ran out unfortunately the
position no longer existed um I think
it's important that we understand and we
can track these changes so that we can
come up with Solutions and uh innovative
ways of addressing the problems the
changes may cause um we are everything
is intertwined we know that our weather
is intertwined with our human experience
with the wildlife around us with the Flo
and the fauna it is intertwined and we
need to be keeping track of the ways in
which we may have negative harmful
effects or in some cases perhaps there
are positive effects but the more we
know the better we can be prepared
um I want to mention um like many people
I am running all of us here we are
running from one meeting to another and
I am missing a meeting that I should be
in now um while I am very happy to take
any questions you have I will also note
that there are a number of people who
are much more interesting than I who can
tell you um about the reasons for this
bill and why they are so supportive and
in fact propo proposed to me that I
bring this forward um I want to also
note that uh there the fiscal Noe is
completely changed since the amended
version I worked very closely with
Senate Health and Human Services Senator
Bradley and with the Department of
Health and Human Services to come up
with a way we could uh reimplement this
position through Grant or other funding
methods so with that I will conclude my
testimony and thank you for your time
and
much thank you so
much
thank
you uh thank you for having us here
today
um I'm before you today not only as a
concerned pediatric nurse and citizen of
New Hampshire but also as a voice for
the health and well-being of our beloved
state and its
inhabitants uh my name is Jacob
mcginness I I am a member of the New
Hampshire Nurses Association uh
specifically the planetary health
committee and I urge you to consider the
vitally important Senate Bill 496 which
proposes the establishment of a program
on climate and health within the New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services in an increasingly
interconnected world the impacts of
climate change reverberate far beyond
environmental concerns they directly
affect human health globally and within
our own communities the World Health
Organization unequivocally declared
climate change as the single biggest
threat facing Humanity here in New
Hampshire we are not insulated from
these effects rather we're witnessing
firsthand the detrimental consequences
of a changing
climate consider the evidence before us
longer growing Seasons altered foliage
patterns more frequent heat waves
dwindling snow pack with three fewer
weeks of snow covered days ice outdates
on Lake wiip pasak creeping earlier each
year intensified participation events
and air quality crises stemming from
distant and near
wildfires these are not merely
fluctuations and weather patterns they
are harbingers of profound shifts that
endanger both our quality of life and
economic Vitality of our
state yet Perhaps what is less readily
apparent are the direct impacts on human
health from the spread of tick and
mosquito born illnesses like lime
disease and West Nile Virus to the rise
in heat related illnesses and deaths the
toll on our communities is already
palpable we are witnessing an increase
in pulmonary and cardiac issues due to
poor air quality
alongside a surge in climate related
mental health distress particularly
among my patients the Youth of our state
I implore you not only to consider the
statistics and reports that you're also
that you will also hear uh the personal
stories of the people that are affected
whether it's a neighbor batt battling
the debilitating effects of Lyme disease
or a family grappling with the mental
health strains exacerbated by climate
anxiety these are voices that underscore
the urgency of action a recent report
estimates the annual cost of climate
change to the US economy at a staggering
$820 billion a figure that continues to
rise
unabated these costs extend beyond mere
Financial burdens they translate into
increased medical expenses and lost
productivity perpet uating a cycle of
suffering and economic strain while
various government agencies in New
Hampshire currently monitor climate
related events none are specifically
tasked with addressing the resultant
Health consequences it is imperative
that we fill this crucial Gap by
establishing a dedicated program on
climate and health within the Department
of Human Health and Human Services this
program would serve as a vital Nexus for
collecting and analyzing data on climate
related Health impacts as well as
devising proactive strategies to
mitigate harm from implementing
prevention approaches to ensuring
appropriate treatment responses and
developing anticip anticipatory
interventions this program would be a
beacon of resilience in the face of
environmental uncertainty the time for
Action is now we cannot afford to delay
any longer in safeguarding the health
and well-being of our communities we
should do everything we can to ensure
that our littlest citizens of our state
experience the full breadth of
childhood by passing Senate Bill 496 we
can assure for future Generations that
our vision for the future is not my
topic rather we can Empower them inform
them and take a significant step towards
the building a healthier more resilient
New Hampshire thank you for your
attention and for the commitment to the
state
red is on okay good afternoon members of
the committee my name is Michelle robers
I'm the bureau chief for public health
protection within the division of Public
Health Services at the Department of
Health and Human Services I don't have
any testimony prepared today but I'm
happy to answer any questions that the
committee may
have
thank you Mr chairman um somebody else
who came before you said that there was
a identical or similar position um at
DHHS prior and could you tell us a
little bit about when that was for how
long it was um what kind of data was
collected that was similar or different
than this bill sure um um so we did have
a climate and health program and it did
support one position within uh the
division of Public Health Services it
was funded through a CDC Grant um for
climate and health and um we originally
got the Grant in 2012 so we we were
fortunate to go through two Grant Cycles
it was four or fivey year Grant cycle so
the last Grant began in 2016 and
unfortunately um we did not get funding
again for a third cycle so uh the
position ended did uh in 2022 I believe
2021 2022 um and then the department did
not have any funds to support uh that
program moving forward that being said
we do have um some data that is on our
data portal that is was part of that so
um that includes um some heat related
Hospital heat related injury and death
we also the department also uh collects
data on uh Lyme disease as well and we
work closely with partner agencies in
particular the Department of
Environmental Services on some of uh
like for instance air quality they do
pretty extensive air quality monitoring
and we have some of that air quality
data also on the Department's data
portal as well um you know what without
funding uh for the position itself some
of the work around education or building
collaborations those are the challenges
that the department has uh to continue
that work without uh appropriate funding
so some of the requirements laid out in
the bill the department wouldn't be able
to do effectively without additional
funding and um I know when the bill was
first introduced the department provided
a fiscal note that kind of outlined some
of those uh
limitations follow thank you
so maybe this is too much of an opinion
um but in your it sounds like you've
been at the department for a while so
you know this history um in your opinion
was the information gathered useful in
terms of guiding Public Health
efforts so I I can tell you been at the
department for five years um I do
believe that the data that's provided
here is useful and is used uh relative
to concerns that people may have
certainly on tick tickborne illnesses um
also heat heat related injury and death
um so yes
do representative Weber
thank you so given that the um position
that was in the original bill has been
taken out and you're directed to do this
without the use of General funds are
you um contemplating that the
work here is simply going to be split up
between existing employees or are you
I'm seeing Mr Williams head moving in
various Direction Cs and I'm trying to
read the tea leaves back there um or or
are you
contemplating simply using funds already
appropriated that are appropriated and
unspent uh to create a position are you
going to be using so I think my question
is current Personnel or are you going to
have another person with funds that are
from somewhere else or from Grants I
mean the grants in here so that that's a
great question um I can say that we
don't have funding currently for this
position um I I know that that we uh
expressed that in our fiscal note that
we would need funding to to for for this
position to do this work um I really
can't speak to whether or not we would
have any other funding in another source
I just know what's what I currently have
that I sort of oversee and manage in
terms of like what's available funding
what we would likely do is try
to the Grant from CDC which we had
before is a is a competitive Grant and
so it's not there isn't enough funding
to support every state so at the next
Grant cycle um we would you know apply
and hopefully you know we would be
successful in getting that funding back
but it's it's it's unknown at this point
and could I have a followup followup
sure uh so this would be a necessary
precursor to being able to apply for
that Grant is that
correct um I'm not sure on that I think
the Grant application would you know we
would have to meet the requirements
spelled out in the Grant application as
to be a successful Grant you know to be
awarded from
CDC
I'm I I think I'll leave it at that okay
because I'm verging on opinions so I'll
step back other questions representative
pazo
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um um if we expect
that there will be more heat related
injuries do we expect that there will be
less tourists who freeze to death in
White Mountains or are killed by
Avalanches or do we expect that less
people will suffer vitamin D deficiency
because it will be nicer weather outside
to
uh have less closes
and
like that's a good question um
I a climate and health program at the
department would help provideed you know
guidance and information and education
uh to communities um and so you know
through that um there's a you know a we
would have appropriate Public Health
messaging to support communities and
people in their decision making
process representative
cofal uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so I'm I'm
looking at lines uh 17 through 25
approximately on page two or yeah in the
in the main text of the bill and I guess
I'm trying to understand why we need a
distinct climate
um climate and health Protection Program
as distinct from other functions of the
department so for example are we not
already providing any guidance any
public education regarding um heat
related injuries are we not already
providing public education information
regarding tickborne illnesses are we not
already providing um information about
um environmental crises such as poor air
quality flooding or or storms and so I'm
I'm trying to
understand how
this what what unmet need is this would
this program be
filling so when I when I look at this
bill so yes we are providing some of
that messaging already but in order to
you know when I read through and look at
at the requirements outlined in the bill
the department doesn't have the Staffing
to be able to proactively go out and and
do that so often times um for instance I
can share an experience uh with last
year with the wildfires um smoke that
was happening up in um in Quebec so New
Hampshire was lucky enough to avoid that
by by virtue of a low pressure system
that was sort of hanging out over New
Hampshire that directed the air quality
around us but we saw pretty high levels
in um massachusett you know I mean uh
New York and other states around us and
so we immediately kind
of pulled our resources as best we could
together to to to to work on a on an
emergency response plan in the event
that the wildfires were to impact us um
but we're so limited in resources that
that pre-planning effort is challenging
without having a specific um you know
position related to climate so the
department can do some minimal work
around it but if we're really focused on
uh bringing parties together and and you
know we did a lot of interventions when
we had the position we worked with
communities on preparedness and building
resiliency and so that's the kind of
work that we'd like to continue to do
but unfortunately given our resources
it's just really challenging um to be
able to do that work along with all of
work other
you also signed up to speak is Joan
Hampshire good thank
you you indicated you want two
minutes don't don't forget to put that
don't forget to put put the microphone
on yeah yeah I'll just summarize thank
you very much for giving me this
opportunity to speak before you um my
name is Joan Whitmer I'm a a 40y year
resident of the town of ammer New
Hampshire and I'm also a registered
nurse who formerly worked for Catholic
Medical Center and also for home health
and hospice care um during my tenure in
the emergency department at CMC we would
note that when there was high heat index
days which there were fewer back when I
did it that we'd see a significant
increase in our patients coming in with
respiratory distress um generally these
were older patients with uh chronic uh
heart failure diseases and
COPD and they would be needing treatment
in an emergency room which as you
probably all know is a very expensive
way to take care of people um if we had
some preventative work that could be
shared with the public in an education
provided we might be able see some of
this reduced over time and that's one of
the benefits of this office in addition
as as Jacob who preceded my testimony
talk from a pediatric perspective
children have much smaller Airways than
adults so they go into respiratory
distress much more quickly than adults
do and so you know when allergies are
significant and or um asthma kicks in
children become very distressed very
quickly and and can lead up to including
death so we want to preserve the health
of our children more than um just about
anything else in the state I would hope
um in addition when I worked for home
health and hospice you know my patients
there um also would experience um
increased respiratory distress such that
our agency actually gave fans to
patients who didn't have air
conditioning as and as many of us know
we've you've lived here as long as I
have most housing stock in the state
does not have air conditioning and so
this becomes a big issue so that's kind
of just my own personal experience with
this and and how health is a broad is
broadly impacted by climate um issues
sorry any questions sure representative
King are you familiar with the
bill how it's presented okay um so this
goes along with the question that
representative cop just asked uh the
previous
testimony um I look at this bill and I
see a lot of it where we're trying to
understand what changes are taking place
and so on um but I only see like a
couple items in here that actually
address a solution a plan on how are we
going to deal with the information that
we're
Gathering W so my question is would you
agree that this bill should actually be
more focused on the solutions than on
the collection of data um one of the
individuals registered here to speak
today actually held the position with
the HHS and I would prefer to defer that
question to him because he can much more
effectively answer it than I can if you
wouldn't mind that's M K helain he'll be
speaking shortly sure um just so I'm
aware of which individual this is do you
that
okay thank
you and thank you for taking the
question certainly I as I said he's he's
much more proficient in answering the
benefits but one of the things I think
um Representatives you all need to
recognize is the impacts on health from
climate change are changing regularly um
for instance there's new studies out
that indicate um that high Micron
particles such as you find in wildfires
are actually um a possible precursor to
um Alzheimer's and other dementias
because they are able to pass through
the naries into the brain and they
create the increased incident they they
believe they create in increased
incidents of plaques that lead to the
these devastating illnesses in latter
years um and this is based on clinical
studies done in in a several locations
so it's it's a new and evolving science
and I think it's really important that
as a state we need to be prepared for um
the changes that are occurring on a
regular basis as we learn more about the
connection between climate and health
representative Leon um thank you Mr
chairman um could you send me the the
clinical information on that I'm also on
this the committee on Alzheimer's and
memory certainly I'd be happy and I'd
just love to be able to review that data
and see if that's something we need to
act on we already have a group that can
do that thank you well happy to any
other questions other
you also signed up to speak is M Gard
from Max Gard from Plymouth New
himself you asked for five minutes sir I
would appreciate if you could do it in
free yeah I can I think I can go under
that um hi uh my name is Max Goddard I'm
representing myself I'm certainly in my
personal capacity here today as a
lifelong resident of New Hampshire but I
do work work for the US uh forest
service pmas ranger district on the
trail crew um and in that capacity um I
have uh seen the direct impacts of uh
you know the change in climate um I've
grown up always hiking in the White
Mountains uh now I'm working in them um
seeing the uh amazing levels of flooding
uh last year was uh my a lot of my job
is essentially managing people in water
um and uh there was a lot of water last
year um and it was uh really impacted
the trails that caused a lot of safety
issues um and things like that are
likely going to increase as time
continues um each year uh as we all know
in the fall uh there's a lot of traffic
that comes up uh and uh you know the
Kang Kang magas highway is uh completely
you know shut down every year for hour
you know takes four hours easily to get
from one side to the other which is
normally a little under an hour drive
and
uh these uh you know increases of you
know traffic and you know predicted you
know events that a lot of people are
coming to witness you know the beautiful
things in our state um are you know
predictable events and because of the
you know very car Centric you know
traffic system and uh inter uh the you
know interstate highway systems that we
have um there's a a lot of pressure put
on the Northern parts of the state when
there are these uh events that bring up
thousands and thousands of cars um when
perhaps you know a railroad or any kind
of other less climate impacting ways of
moving these people up into the state
could be looked at and because we don't
have that the negative Health impacts of
the resulting uh you know just
Mass Dead uh you know highways for hours
and hours and obviously two days ago we
all experienced that uh very very
succinctly uh with the eclipse and the
12h hour you know drives back uh to our
houses and I even know some of the
representatives on this committee were
uh complaining about the response and
the you know how that EV you know uh ESS
of the northern part of the state you
know was operated and I actually thought
that the governor did a really good job
of uh mitigating and
managing what was an impossible scenario
thousands and thousands of cars going
down like three roads with you know one
lane on the Notch and like there's
there's nowhere for them to go because
obviously how could there be for 10,000
cars um and uh so I appreciate apprciate
you know uh the vice chair
representative Leon and her criticisms
of that uh operation uh and must you
must appreciate and recognize that these
impacts are significant on our state and
we should be looking at the health
impacts uh I'm I'm glad you know I don't
think there was any major you know uh
health concerns uh you because of the
successful you know mitigation and
management of the state but uh these uh
events are you know the eclipse might be
you know once in 40 years but every
single year we just accept that the Kink
just you wrap up sir that's that's all I
have okay any questions yes
representative paza thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question uh
as you uh on the trail crew maybe you
have some uh colleagues uh uh managing
trails and forests we talk about
pollution from
wildfires if we expect this threat to
increase uh are there any measures uh
like if in the last 100 years New
Hampshire got more trees more Forest
growing around and managing Forest is
very important to prevent wild fires
could you speak a little bit is there
anything being done
about New Hampshire Wildfire management
and prevention yes um well I actually I
do have a a little bit of wildfire
experience I've I've gone out west uh
for a service and uh um on the Cedar
Creek Fire and uh um another fire in
Idaho and um I've I've gotten to respond
to a few of the smaller uh Escape
campfires that we've had on the White
Mountains uh the past couple of years um
in a very small capacity you know not a
senior firefighter by any means um and
uh I have you know I I have seen the the
growing concern of the you know increase
in fires and the increase in heat index
which puts more pressure on these fires
the droughts that we've had um and I I
know the federal the forest service I I
I mean I I'm pretty sure they seem to be
aware of you know the climate impacts
and they're looking at at that uh on a
state level I'm not a state employee not
that I'm here as Federal capacity even
but that ANW you question yeah thank you
representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for following my
social media some of the hall h
conversations about it there actually
may be some better solutions to do that
but that's why it's great that people
can have these conversations um so thank
you for bringing what you have to us and
um and I appreciate what you do for us
in the forest service I wanted to be a
forest stranger when I grew up so thank
you for doing
this okay any other
questions seeing none thank you sir
thank
you also signed up to speak is Matthew
Cahalan from cona representing
himself hopefully I pronounced that last
name
right
you've asked for two minutes sir great
yeah two minutes I we'll keep it uh
quick so uh thank you inviting me or
being here to speak uh chairman Donald
the members of the committee I'm Matthew
Kain um I was the program manager who
Rand it from this previous climate and
health program from 2012 to 2022 when
the the funding ran out I'm not
currently at the HHS employee want to
make that clear I'm here as an informed
citizen because I'm very still very
interested in this topic and I want to
provide uh feed back um I worked in
public health for three decades mostly
in environmental health issues I feel
like I understand the big picture of it
and I think what you get with this
program if you're Bring It On is that
balance view which is lacking right it's
lacking in the media it's lacking in a
lot of places you get something like you
see in the safe health impact assessment
where you get a sense of how different
problems relate and climate change isn't
the worst problem it's one of those
issues we have to deal within the state
along with weather along with other
things along with you know uh a lot of
the different issues that are out there
and I like think that balance is
important um I care deeply about the
problem of climate change but I also
divide it up between weather and our
traditional climate and anthropogenic
climate change I we need to understand
all those if we're going to try and
understand the health impacts that are
coming from all those um I think one of
your concerns is a recent assessment of
climate research showed that there's
over over 50,000 papers published per
year research papers on climate very
hard to keep on top of that over a thou
thousand of those make it into the popul
media right where we get a sense of
those and a lot of those relate to the
most dramatic impacts and also to the
health impacts and I think that comes
back to you here right you have to kind
of take those media reports and take
that concern from the citizens and try
to respond in some ways I think having a
program within DHHS that does that is
really helpful for you someone who can
prioritize and assess and understand I
did send her on a fact sheet well you'll
notice in the fact sheet which I helped
write and put together with some other
staff is um it has a balanced view it
doesn't and try to say we're not in the
worth crisis ever it tries to say we've
got real concerns related to weather to
climate they relate to other issues that
we've heard today like respiratory
Health um and uh tickborne disease and
things like that those are some really
important things in New Hampshire and I
think that kind of position would
provide um perspective um on that um in
there I talk about some of the things we
accomplished but I think one of the
questions that came up is why do we need
a program like this I think a
coordinated role is really important um
it brings together all the other state
agencies to say well we all have a piece
of the pi of the pie here we're kind of
seeing it from different views but if we
have to answer our Public Health
question prioritize it and find
resources for it that's what the
position can really help with I think
the program is limited in some ways
previously um mostly because of the data
we could get and I think a new program
would do well um to focus on a couple
issues improve ability to collect data
on flooding and pollen in New Hampshire
those are missing data pieces improve
ability to collect data on health
impacts ESP esecially at the primary
care center set setting we're very good
at looking at hospital and emergency
department data um develop better
methods develop interventions to prevent
people are talking about how we going to
act here I think it's about getting on
the ground and working with local
communities and identify barriers
limiting access to Safe affordable
disaster resilient housing you could
start wrapping up please all right so uh
and that's important because that's part
of the state health information plan too
in closing my view as a health educator
is that finding truth is a lot of your
job and I think truth is a combination
of two factors accurate information and
trusted sources and I believe this
program could provide both of those um
those two valuable assets to help the
legislator executive branch and the
public better understand these concerns
and I'm happy to answer any questions
that anybody has those for I know some
came up
previously representative
bazo thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question uh let's say New
Hampshire Department of Health and Human
Services doesn't know how to deal with
longer growing period and longer pollen
U allergies uh but uh we have a state
south of us why can't we just ask
Massachusetts Massachusetts you have
longer growing period you have longer
Poland you maybe you have more more heat
exposures tell us how to deal with it
yeah yeah I mean you're right in away
right we're we're our our climate is
changing and it's going to be similar to
people states that are to the South us
so we should study those populations
talk to those people say what have you
discovered before I've often found in
legisl proposing a a solution for
Massachusetts isn't always the best
approach to take but I hear what you're
saying with there's a lot to learn from
people who have done it before and we
won't be on our own well there'll be
people who've experienced it and be able
to talk about
that representative Leon thank you Mr
chairman and thank you so much for being
here and especially bringing the
expertise you have um in another bill we
had had some information on data
collection and data analysis and that
was collecting data that was already
available within the state and the
expected Financial impact of that is
very similar to what I see here but it
sounds to me like in your pre in your in
the previous role and what you envision
for this for whoever takes on that
responsibility there' be a lot more data
collection and a lot more needs to that
um and I'm curious how much you think it
would cost on an ongoing basis in order
to appropriately fill out this Vision um
of of what you see the the need for this
role and the need for this program in
order to actually address these issues
in the comprehensive way that it seems
that you think we that you believe we
should do sure we did a couple of
contracts when we had this program in
place with the USGS um and with UNH and
others to say could you help us gather
this data and realistically most of the
data was already available um it's the
same when we collect information on
emergency room data it's already an
available data set that's collected by
DHHS and man so I don't see a specific
strong new data collection system that
will require a lot of money we did a
small grant for $7,000 to the UNH Survey
Center and we tried to understand better
how do people feel about uh climate
change what are their opinions what are
their perspectives I think that's
helpful new data because it adds to data
in the past and helps us understand
what's happening now I did say in here
specifically we're missing a pollen
system in New Hampshire I tried to
restart one through peers at UNH about
10 years ago 15 years ago and I was not
successful in keeping that going but
that I think would cost in the range of
80 to $100,000 a year I've talked to
peers at New Hampshire Dees and they
said we'd install pollen stations along
with our air quality data and maintain
it if you could get us the capital cost
of a $100,000 to do it that's what it
was 10 years ago it could be less now um
because it uses digital technology um
and we're missing data also on Mental
Health but that's out there it's just
harder to access and harder to link with
extreme weather events so I I think that
the number I would have would probably
be around there for it but we don't have
to do that it's we want to expand it
thank you other
you also signed up to speak is Paul
Fredricks from exor representing
himself
so you've asked for four minutes you
keep to Clos the threee I'd appreciate
it okay uh thank you chairman McDonald
and the committee for having me back uh
again my name is Paul friedricks I'm a
retired family doctor from exiter I'm
passing around my my prepared comments
but I'm going to deviate from them to
try to answer questions that have been
raised good questions have been raised
about the the bill this afternoon um and
there are some references included in
that I wanted to make the point that
that clearly
climate in New Hampshire is changing and
I speak to that in my written testimony
you can't have lived here 40 years like
I have and not know that we had a 25y
old guy up here a few minutes ago who
said he's seen it in his life toown I I
think that's pretty non-debatable that
climate changing the other thing that's
non- debatable is that the climate
change is is changing some of our health
concerns when I started practicing you
know Lyme disease uh we'd say that if
you hadn't been South of the Border to
Southern Massachusetts of Connecticut
your fever and rash couldn't be Lyme
disease because you don't get it in New
Hampshire that's changed and other
diseases are changing as well and uh the
other important fact to know is that our
state P division of Public Health is not
a plush division they don't have a lot
of resources they don't have excess
staff um you know the lead programs and
things like that have been largely
dependent on federal funds for years and
to say that they're going to manage look
at these changes and uh not only note
them follow them but educate the the
population the communities are are are
population and our patients about these
health problems they just don't have
those resources so the point of this
bill is to say this is a priority at
least one person in the whole HHS should
be thinking about this coordinating this
getting out information educating the
public about it for example bosis how
many people here have heard of bosis
good some of you have much of the most
of the population has not the incidence
of bbcos in New Hampshire is up 372 per
in the past decade whereas in Maine it's
up 1, 1400% in Vermont 1, more than 1,
1600% you know um representative Palos
spoke about changing weather and
temperatures and hiking in the White
Mountains but yes people who have all
this time hiked in the White Mountains
in this summer aren't necessarily
factoring in The increased heat the heat
stress and the the emergency evacuations
when they devel heat stroke on the
mountains in the summer and things like
that so yes people in Georgia know how
to hike in the mountains in the summer
but New Hampshire residents aren't used
to that we're we're people of habit we
get used to certain things we don't
expect things allergy season you got to
start taking your allergy medicine two
weeks earlier than you used to and but
people are saying I always started my
allergy medicine on April first I'm keep
doing that we need to get out and
educate people with asthma and other
disease that will get them in the
emergency room if they don't know that
that they have to anticipate the changes
and factor that in so we're asking for a
recognition of the changes and climate
recognition and the health problems that
have resulted from that here in New
Hampshire and the way that we have to
adapt as a population for the safety and
health of our population and think one
people one person in the state
advocating that that is not excessive
thank you very much thank you any
you also signed up to speak is sedon
Savage from conquer
representing thank you very much um s
Savage I'm sorry my name is Sedin Savage
okay and it's a pleasure to be here
thank you um Mr chair members of the
committee I give it to around three
minutes ma'am three minutes okay I will
do that you've heard from others um I
I'm a physician I'm actually a pain
medicine and an addiction medicine
physician um I've worked in the state
for over 40 years I've been on the
faculty at Dartmouth all that time and
testifying before this committee often
around opioids pain and addiction so I'm
really stepping out of my area of
expertise and my usual professional role
to come to you today and I'm doing that
because along with many of my colleagues
who are here I really believe that the
impact on of climate change on health is
the single most important health issue
that we are facing as a state as a
country and as a globe going forward um
it is really an existential uh issue for
all of us particularly for our children
and particularly for our children's uh
children and our grandchildren um so um
uh I really want to focus on why this
office will be important um one of the
things that I been doing with growing
concern around um climate and health is
um helping to convene a group of
researchers clinicians and Educators
across the Dartmouth system where I've
worked um for most of my career um both
at Dartmouth health and um the
university there we're coming together
to really try and address these issues
in a coordinated way and network our
efforts so there are a number of efforts
within the medical community that are
Happ happen we're working on educating
students uh medical students so that
they understand the impact of climate
and health we weren't raised
understanding these impacts and so that
they're prepared to address the impacts
and help prevent the impacts among their
patients we're trying to make our health
system more environmentally sustainable
we know that Health Systems contribute
about 10% of our country's um greenhouse
gases and we're part of the problem we
have to do better um we are trying to
support practicing Physicians and
connecting the dots between their
patients illnesses and um climate and
health and many of us are trying to
educate the public directly about the
impacts and how to present themselves
but how this relates to this program
that we are supporting is that in order
to do this well to do it efficiently and
cost effectively we really need to
Target our limited resources so we need
data um of of all types to be able to um
uh think about how to do this well
questions like where in the state
regionally what data on how this is
regionally impacting the state um where
are tick and mosquito born illnesses
more most prevalent um what are the
regional patterns of poor air quality
that are related to Wildfire smoke or to
other forms of air pollution where
should we put cooling stations where
should we put tornado shelters to
protect from extreme weather what
regions agriculture are most vulnerable
to flooding we need data on the
vulnerability of different populations
which young athletes which kinds of
outdoor workers are most vulnerable to
heat related stress and to possible
death as a result which of our urban
populations are most uh affected by heat
Islands or by congregate air pollution
do we how do rural seniors cope uh when
weather events prevent their caregivers
from supporting them so we need data on
strategies which are most effective and
cost effective we don't have endless
resources stop wrapping up please okay I
will start start winding up so data is
one of our needs our other need is for
uh Avenues to disseminate strategies
that we know work and information so
that people can protect ourselves we see
this office as um Dr Frederick said as
uh onepoint shopping so that there's one
person who's in charge of helping to
orchestrate all these various activities
that are going on to protect our
citizens so with that I'll wind up and I
thank you very much thank you are there
any questions
okay I'm saying none thank you very
much okay no one else has signed up to
testify does anyone else wish to testify
bill different Bill
okay when you get back to you see it
I'll ask you about the blue sheet I'll
back okay and know what was online L on
and online was 49 in support six
opposed okay very good thank
you all right if there's no one else who
wishes to testify I'm going to close the
public hearing on sp sp 496 FN and open
oh well actually I can't yet it's not
2:30 so uh we're going to be in recess
minutes
ch
e
hello everyone and welcome back to our
last bill of the day Senate Bill 567
FN and I'll recognize the prime sponsor
and welcome back Senator Becky Whitley
thank you Mr chair and good afternoon
again members of the committee for the
record my name is Becky Whitley I'm
honored to represent Senate District
which includes the wonderful communities
of Bo conquered Penacook and hopkington
uh today I bring forward for your
consideration Senate Bill
567 as amended by the Senate so what you
have before you is a bipartisan uh
Amendment um Senator Carson and I work
together um because of the importance of
the moment here so you will see that the
bill as amended requires the Department
of Health and Human Services to submit a
a report uh To Us by November 1st and
the report requires uh uh the contents
of the report include identifying
potential actions to protect and expand
access to mistone and mistol identifying
ways to increase Outreach and education
about access to mistone and M mistol
Mile prol and identifying barriers to
protecting or expanding access to these
medications so if you don't know if
you're not aware mffa prisone was first
approved by the FDA more than 20 years
ago and has since been used by more than
5 million people in the US to safely end
their
pregnancies the legislature of the State
of New Hampshire has actually recognized
already the importance of access to myth
prisone since 1991 when New Hampshire
was the first state in the nation to
adopt a state resolution urging the US
Food and Drug Administration to allow
clinical clinical trials of myth or
prisone in medication abortions the same
drugs used to produce a medication
abortion are also treated also used to
treat a miscarriage and I just want to
be clear about that these medications
are not only used in medications
abortion but they are used in other
situations to treat a miscarriage which
if left untreated can put patients at
risk for severe infection future
fertility or even death this method of
care has helped ensure that patients are
able to make their own private medical
decisions and has expanded access to
reproductive Health Care something that
is in dire threat in this country but
unfortunately abortion medications have
now become the latest Target by
extremists to remove even more access to
abortion care in our country if
successful anti-abortion activists who
are trying to eliminate access to medic
medication abortion will be increasing
the chance of poor health outcomes for
all pregnant women not just those who
have chosen abortion I want to be clear
that attacks on myph aistone are
strictly politically motivated
instigated and funded by extreme actors
to further their agenda to ban abortion
birth control and other sexual and
reproductive healthare Nationwide but we
will not let that happen in New
Hampshire not on our watch not in a Live
Free or Die State and that's because New
Hampshire has and continues to be a
pro-choice State a survey from
breakthrough campaign shows that a super
majority of granite Staters 87% support
reproductive freedom and 64% of granite
Staters expect State elected officials
to protect or expand B abortion rights
with that in mind last June my
colleagues and I asked Governor sonunu
to take action to protect access to
abortion and more specifically to
protect access to abortion by joining a
lawsuit to protect access to Mya prisone
and by issuing an executive order like
so many other Governors did following
the Dos case which overturned roie Wade
unfortunately Governor shunu failed to
take any action to protect reproductive
freedom in New Hampshire which is why
this bill is all is so necessary I have
respectfully asked that you stand with
me and other members of the Senate to
protect reproductive freedom in the
granite state and support Senate bill 50
567 um I'm happy to take any questions
but there are folks behind me that could
speak to uh the protocols for the use of
abortion medications so I can defer
those technical questions I appreciate
your consideration of this bill um and
urge you to vote it a to pass thank you
very much thank you are there any
representative CL off
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
presenting the bill and taking my
question um the bill uh talks about two
drugs and you mostly covered M prone may
you briefly talk about M the second one
Mr prol is it a newer
drug so it um the use of those two drugs
is a is a protocol in abortion
medication but there are providers
behind me that could answer in more
detail what that protocol entails
thank you for the question any other
you also signed up to speak is
representative thank you uh Mary hacket
Phillips representing Hanover and L here
today to speak as co-sponsor and support
of hp56 7 just reiterating my comments
of support given in January when the
senate committee on Judiciary first
received the Bill I'm here to relay an
important constituent story for your
consideration there's an OBGYN physician
practicing at Dartmouth Hitchcock
Medical Center in lebin who is also
professor at geel school of medicine in
Handover and a resident there this
doctor is licensed to practice in both
Vermont in New Hampshire and has
reported to me directly that he
perceives the ongoing attacks limiting
his medical practice in New Hampshire as
a push to stop offering his provider
service in our state this doctor has
contemplated moving his entire clinical
pra practice exclusively to Vermont
because of its more hospitable
environment and this doctor feels that
the laws regulating abortion care are an
unfair intrusion on his medical
decision-making which follow national
standards of care and they're an
intrusion upon his professional
expertise this law have passed and the
study committee when undertaken will
provide this doctor an important signal
of support that New Hampshire trusts its
OBGYN providers and values their
difficult but meaningful work providing
vital access to abortion medication is
an important part of his clinical work
and passage of this bill will assure
doctors like him that New Hampshire is
serious about expanding Healthcare
access and serious about giving
providers all the tools they need to
practice their trade and serve their
patients this would be an important
moral Victory after recent attacks on
their profession
and um it would show that New
Hampshire's legislatur are serious about
putting people before
politics second I just wanted to say
that I've heard there's some concern
that New Hampshire DHHS may be limited
in contributing to the study committee
work and compiling the commissioner's
report out of a fear or some limitation
by DHHS because um of the executive
council's refusal to fund Planned
Parenthood contracts as I understand the
lb's fiscal note for the study committee
bill is a total cost less than $10,000
and we know that's below the threshold
for executive Council review on
contracts while DHHS would be the agency
compiling the report through this
committee study they should not be
perceived as avoiding a contractual
review um by the executive committee
because our legislature if we so choose
will be the a uh and not the agency will
be charged um with the intent for the
study and um how that would take place
well below the threshold amount um by
directing that work so no General funds
are to be expended for the study report
as we understand it but rather federal
funds and grants are to be sought to
accomplish the goal so I urge the
committee please don't get stuck on that
point lastly I'd like to share my
support for the intended work of the
committee uh we all know that the
Supreme Court of the United States is
reviewing the FDA versus Alliance of
hypocritic medicine and that case is
pending um but it should be noted that
many legal analysts anticipate that the
court will uphold the fda's authority
and continues to make myristol access
legal uh regardless of that ruling
however the information gathering in
this commit by this committee is
critical and identifying the ways to
protect and ex uh expand the access of
both M mistone and
misoprostol and the barriers to this
same as well as the educational
component for public awareness for the
safe and effective drug giving pregnant
people control over their bodies their
lives and their family sizes found to
Grant sters fundamental freedoms and
robust Statewide economy that's why it's
so important so important to keep the
bipartison bill as amended by the senate
in its current form I just urge the
committee please do not lose track of
that original intent um by perhaps
offering some sort of substantive
Amendment changing the subject of the
studies committee's work so for those
three reasons I'd like to urge you to
support the bill has been introduced to
your committee and I'd be happy to
answer any questions you have thank you
representative Seth k
thank you Mr chair uh thank you for
taking
questions these two drugs they're not
over the counter is that correct I'm
sorry I'm not a physician I'm not aware
of the prescribing information I do
believe that you need a prescription to
get it which would require doctor with
and relationship okay thank you are you
aware of any current roadblocks to
getting access to those right now I I'm
unaware myself I'm honestly curious how
difficult are are there doctors that
wouldn't prescri mean what do you know
of that's making it difficult for well I
just spoke of the largest barrier the
Supreme Court review case under pending
review now so it's a potential decision
by the Supreme Court that you know that
FDA approved drug is no longer going to
be available so being able to study
other ways to access life-saving
medication U abortion would is just is
an important issue um so I think that
does fall under the study committee's um
charge in this instance and that you
would you know that would be one of the
barriers um that the specific drug could
not be used anymore so you'd need to
find you know potentially other options
so you would say this is more of a
proactive piece of legislation the
problem doesn't exist yet but it may so
we should we should do something now or
um I wouldn't uh couch it in that frame
um I would say that that is one of the
current challenges I'm sure there are
many more and there are probably folks
behind me who can speak to the
intricacies of that a little more in
detail thank you thank you
representative fedus for closing the
door by the way representative Leon and
then representative Weber uh thank you
Mr chairman and thank you representative
for being here um it sounds like there's
an attempt to proactively deal with if
the FDA doesn't allow the drug to be
done here would it make more sense for
us to look to what other states have
done to be able to import drugs from
Canada because if it's no longer
available as an FDA approved drug here
in the United States we'd need to get it
from somewhere and Canada has those
drugs and their there is a process for
that thank you uh representative for the
question I I would say that any option
on the table to increase Access to
Health Care for Women in particular is a
great place to start I think this
committee um given that they'll need to
be identifying barriers to medication
abortion as well as um to expanding and
protecting medication abortion and
educating the public on that matter um
is you know that would all fall
underneath that umbrella I believe um if
if the committee so choose chose
uh you know whether or not Canadian
prescription drugs being imported to the
United States for this specific reason I
don't know that that's um within the
scope of this bill but um that would be
up to the committee to determine thank
Weber I was going to ask if you
know uh being from Northern parts about
parts of the state where
uh prescribing Physicians or nurse
practitioners might be fewer and farther
between than they are here in
conquer um and uh availability at
pharmacies and things like that might be
currently an issue uh just given our
provider issues and if that's better a
question for me to ask somebody else
just declin to answer and I'll hold on
to it thank you for the question
representative and uh what I can tell
you anecdotally is that yes I I recently
attended the retirement party of a
senior member of the OBGYN surgical
Department um who was hired hired many
many years ago of course and was trained
um to handle some of the most complex
pregnancy uh cases and um surgical cases
for OBGYN issues in the state um and
upon his retirement there was no one
adequately trained in the state to be
able to fully take over his case load
and patient load so I do know that you
know we are seeking we are approaching
um kind of a proverbial Cliff of folks
who are retiring with expertise without
adequate Replacements in place now so
what that does is create a bit of a
desert right for service areas um
including um the service area of the
state of New Hampshire because we all
know that the tertiary care system at
Dartmouth stretches pretty far so um yes
that is a continual concern we all know
there's physician shortages PA shortages
nursing shortages traveler nurse
shortages and budgetary concerns that
affect all this these problems as well
so um of course the barriers are more
than just um procedural we know that
they're infrastructural barriers as well
so thank you for the
question other
you also signed up to to speak are Kayla
Montgomery and Liz Canada from Planned
England make sure you put your
microphone thank you good afternoon
members of the committee my name is
Kayla Montgomery I'm the vice president
of public affairs for Planned Parenthood
of Northern New England um so I'm just
going to speak a little bit about uh
medication abortion and then I'm going
to hand it over my colleague who will
speak a little bit more about the
Supreme Court case that we um just just
had oral arguments in um so okay
medication abortion is also known as the
abortion pill it is a safe and effective
way to end an early pregnancy up to 11
weeks or 77 days after your last Miss
period serious complications happen in
less than onethird of 1% of cases it's
safer than other common medicines if
it's penicillin and Viagra at CL parent
of Northern New England medication
abortion is provided at three of our
four Health Centers so in Manchester
keen and as of December at our Dairy
location it is an option for some
patients via tella Health as well with
our trained and licensed
clinicians now we say abortion pill but
it's actually a series of five pills
using two different drugs the first one
is nephop pistone and the second one is
misool so the patient will take one
metapristone which blocks progesterone
which is the hormone needed for
pregnancy and and then the the patient
will take four misael pills which are
placed in the cheeks and this is the
drug that empties the contents of the
uterus so this combination the two drugs
that combination is the standard um
medication abortion protocol now
medication abortion it is treated the
same way as a procedural abortion in
that the intake procedure and the
counseling are the same the difference
is that a medication abortion the actual
abortion will happen at home and a
procedural abortion happens in the
health center over 5 million people in
the United States have used methone
which has been FDA approved for over 20
years and many um abortion patients they
choose medication abortion nationally
this number is 53% but at PPN the number
is much higher it's about
70% people choose medication abortion
over procedural abortion for a number of
reasons most commonly to be in the
comfort of your own home or on your own
schedule some people also feel it's less
invasive but it is not for everyone it's
a personal choice and that's why Planned
Parenthood offers both options it's also
important to note that um medication
abortion and emergency contraception are
not the same thing medication abortion
which is the subject of uh the bill
today it's taken to safely end a
pregnancy whereas emergency
contraception is one pill it's available
over the counter and it's taken after
unprotected sex occurs to make sure a
pregnancy doesn't happen so they're not
the same thing an emergency
contraception will not end a pregnancy
and I'll turn it over to
Liz thank you so for the record my name
is Liz Canada I'm the advocacy director
of plan Parenthood Northern New England
and Planned Parenthood New Hampshire
action fund so uh the previous speakers
brought up the Supreme Court case and I
just wanted to give a little bit more
context so right now before the Supreme
and organizations who have sued the US
Food and Drug Administration over its
approval of mytha priston and the case
uses junk science to allege that mytha
priston was wrongfully approved by the
FDA 22 years ago and what they are
trying to do is to remove mistone from
the market
entirely this attack on medication
abortion is a blatant attempt to try to
pass the deao abortion
ban the fda's approval as you all know
being on this Committee of course
applies to
uh drugs in every state so the case
would undermine any state laws or
protections and would even impact our
neighbors in Vermont who passed a
constitutional amendment and protected
abortion in their constitution it would
still affect that state and other states
like it uh if this ruling takes effect
from the Supreme Court it will have
nationwide impacts including here in New
Hampshire access to myth prone can
become much more restricted this is an
outrageous attack it's politically
motivated it's instigated and funded by
extreme anti-abortion actors and it's to
further the agenda to ban abortion but
also to impact things like birth control
and other sexual and reproductive
healthare the consequences therefore go
far beyond abortion care and it could
also stifle medic uh medic uh medical
Innovation my my apologies Abend the
country's drug approval process and put
every approved medication in the
political
crosshairs so the Supreme Court as Kayla
just mentioned the Supreme Court just
had oral arguments two weeks ago on this
case we expect a decision to come out by
the end of June which is very similar to
the timeline we saw two years ago when
the Supreme Court overturned Robie Wade
ending the federal constitutional
protection for the right to abortion um
so the bill in front of you Senate Bill
567 I heard the prime sponsor bring this
up this was a bipartisan floor amendment
in the Senate it passed on a Voice vote
it was you know strongly supported in
that way it directs the Department of
Health and Human Services to issue a
report to show accessibility
opportunities to protect access and
potential barriers that exist in New
Hampshire and so we urge you to vote all
to pass on Senate Bill
567 thank you any questions
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking questions do
you know where these two drugs are
States I'm not sure but they are
distributed in the United States our
distributor is United States based
followup
follow uh if they were banned at the
federal level um do you believe that
like cannabis these drugs could be
produced in the United States and
continue to be distributed uh
Statewide that feels like a little bit
over my pay grade um I will say that
Planned Parenthood of course follows the
laws of where we operate so we are main
Vermont New Hampshire we follow the laws
of New Hampshire so if that is something
that the state of New Hampshire wanted
to do and it was within the law then we
would do that but we certainly wouldn't
go outside of the realm of the State of
New Hampshire what about federal law I
mean I I'd have to see what that would
look like I don't and the other
clarification is this case is about the
approval through the FDA process so it's
not about manufacturing it it's about
how it is approved and so one of the
potential outcomes of this case is it
rolls it back to when it can be
prescribed for for pregnancy so right
now as Kayla said earlier it's up to the
11th week they could roll that back and
say well you can't use it unless it's up
to you know an earlier week than that so
it's really about the approval process
itself through the FDA thanks
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for that that is
very interesting so if they remove the
approval for it for abortion would it
remain approved for other uses in the
United
States that's an excellent question I
think that's a question that we're all
wondering as we wait for the Supreme
Court decision to come out sorry if I
can follow up is there an approval for
it other for any other use other than
abortion in the United States and if
there's not would having a pathway to
import it from Canada or another state
be a high priority so that we can
maintain access to it because if it is
approved for another use in the United
States we passed a bill um last term
that allows for off Lael prescribing
within the state so if these drugs
remain approved for other uses the fact
that it's not approved for abortion
would not have an impact on it wouldn't
have an impact on doctors in New
Hampshire because they are protected for
prescribing for an off Lael use as long
as they have informed consent so is is
maintaining access to these drugs the
primary goal and therefore looking at
any path whether through off Lael use or
through importation from Canada the
you so again this we don't know what the
Supreme Court's going to say
um I listen you know we listen to oral
arguments I don't think that is
necessarily something that was brought
up um but we know that whatever happens
at the Supreme Court it's going to
affect every single state so regardless
of um off Lael use in in New Hampshire
it's going to affect the whole country
so um I think we don't know I guess it's
the short
answer uh representative Weber and then
representative Seth
King that brings up a follow-up question
for for me and and um uh if you know it
may may also be above your pay grade
but if the approval is rolled
back
um is importation from Canada then even
legal um absent a prescriber in Canada
who is willing to prescribe in
Canada and yeah here because Physicians
if there's
prohibition on physician
prescription um setting aside the issue
of of our own local laws because the
Supreme Court controls over that um is
it even legal to get supplies from
elsewhere yeah I I understand that
question I think it goes back to Liz's
point about the fact that it's not we're
not talking about a straight band if if
they roll back it's going to go back to
the 2016 protocols and part of that is
going from 11 weeks to six weeks so
maybe maybe the drug will be available
for some people but it is a um it's a
reduction of access so whether or not
you have the pills from Canada does not
necessarily mean that we can prescribe
them if someone is say seven weeks along
you also want to just jump in and say
these types of questions which are all
excellent are such a good example of
what has happened since Robie Wade was
overturned right like the legal
landscape and the chaos that's ensuing
the types of court cases that are now
allowed to go through and are in
Jeopardy and so like all of this is an
excellent example of like what has
happened over the last two years and you
know more to come regardless even with
what happens with this case specifically
representative Seth King and then
representative Leon thank you again Mr
chair you mentioned that your Dairy
Manchester and Keen planned parenthood's
offer this um where is your fourth
Planned Parenthood and why doesn't it
offer those drugs thank you um it's a
great question our fourth location is an
exitor and um it's uh it just is not a
space that we have available for
medication abortion we are working at
expanding um some other locations we
just expanded a few in Vermont um but
it's just um it just hasn't happened
it's not something you can set up
overnight you certainly have to be
training people it's cost money it's
there's a lot that goes into it so we
would love to expand to our fourth
location someday um but probably not
this year representative Lon thank you
Mr chairman uh thank you so the um
Supreme Court is that only for the 2000
approval because you just said that it
would roll back to the 1996 approval I
think she said 2016 the 2016 approval is
possible okay so yeah there's
arguments and what we saw you know with
the do's decision right like the the
case that was first introduced was then
changed into overturning roie Wade
entirely so there are a different there
are are many paths that the majority of
the Supreme Court could make but like
one of them is rolling back to a
specific earlier approval process
another is removing it from the market
entirely there are a lot of different
decisions they can make um and so we
can't necessarily predict what that's
going to be we just know that the
Supreme Court the majority is not
friendly towards abortion exess okay
thank you so if it does roll it back to
a previous approval based on our off
label you will still be able to
prescribe it so if it is only for the
most recent approval that has had the
lawsuit against it there is not a threat
to access to this in New Hampshire
because our off Lael prescribing would
allow uh uh somebody to prescribe it
even outside of that six week approval
process because through the off label
prescribing law and the protection
because there are data that are already
being cited for this this would not
impact access so long as there was any
approvable use for these drugs in the
United States so this is not something
that is the same concern in other states
the state of New Hampshire throw our off
Lael prescribing as long as it is not
entirely removed from the market it
still would remain useful and it would
still be remain lawful for it to be
prescribed because the federal
government does not set which drugs can
be prescribed it's simply an access to
them it state law prevails and the
medical boards Prevail on how it's done
and this is already protected through
New Hampshire state law so I just want
you to recognize that it's already
protected a lot more than other states
sure I I certainly hope that's the case
and I hope that once the Supreme Court
um rules that we can come together as a
state and make that really clear I also
want to add though that there are some
other restrictions that would they could
roll back including tah Health um so
that would no longer be an option for
medication
abortion other
questions seeing no other question thank
you also signed up to speak is Kevin
dandro from conquered representing
himself and you've asked for three
minutes
ahead and your microphone's already on
they left it on for
you thank you Mr chairman committee
members my name is Kevin dandro I'm a
member of the conquered Church of Christ
their m agree with me on this issue and
I'm also a law student at UNH Franklin
Pierce School of Law I'm not
representing the university today so I'm
urging the committee to vote inexpedient
to legislate uh this bill for quite a
few reasons um the original object of
this bill was to direct the Department
of Health and Human Services to expand
abortion access and that is not
something that needs to be done in New
Hampshire like we said we are very
pro-life state it is completely
unnecessary to involve the government in
this matter and that brings me to this
next point is that this bill that's
amended because the first one couldn't
pass this one is also completely
unnecessary the fiscal note has been
reduced to less than 10,000 and there
are so many Industries there's the
pharmaceutical industry and all of the
whole abortion industry they have plenty
of resources that could cover
even conducting more narrowly focused
legislation or uh Media or advertising
that can get essentially the same thing
across that this bill is aiming to
produce and essentially what you're
doing is you're forcing New Hampshire
taxpayers to pay for something that is
quite unnecessary and that would also
violate the New Hampshire Constitution I
was recently told by members of
committee even that the New Hampshire
Constitution protects the minority and
even if the majority of people do want
abortion access you can't force the
minority to pay for it especially when
they have very reasonable and not
extreme at all religious beliefs that do
oppose abortion you can't force these
people to pay for somebody else's
abortion that they find in their
conscience just so morally wrong and for
those reasons I thank you for the
opportunity to share My Views today and
I'm open to any questions are there any
questions representative palaza thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question uh maybe you're not the right
question to ask uh about uh you're not a
medical professional but according to
your data do you agree with previous
statement that uh this these drugs are
women do I agree that it's safe for
women um I I am not sure if it's safe
for women but in my view it's not safe
for any of the babies that are being
killed thank you other
questions not seeing any thank you sir
thank
you also signed up to speak is Jason
life you've asked for four minutes sir
if you could keep a closer the three I'd
appreciate it all right thank you Mr
chair my name is Jason Hennessy I'm the
president for New Hampshire right to
life which is New Hampshire's largest
pro-life organization representing many
pro lifers across the state I also have
a PhD in computational sciences and
statistics which is relevant to to some
of the to some of this what I'm going to
testify on um
in summary I we encourage you to vote
itl on this bill for three major reasons
the first one is that this this bill
would increase actual danger to New
Hampshire pregnant women in two
different ways the second one is that
this is really uh something that should
be done in the private sector you
know instead of the state finding ways
to advertise this drug uh and the third
one is that this is really a solution in
search of a problem so so first
uh about two-thirds of women who have
had abortions report that they were
either coerced or that it was
inconsistent with their values 24%
reported that their abortions were
unwanted or
coed so the abortion pill especially
with tahal the way that the FDA has
opened it it it makes that even a bigger
issue uh I'd like to draw your attention
to Brooke Fisk Brooke was 17 to week
pregnant when she went to go visit the
father of her child of her child and
rather than offering to help raise the
child he as a doctor had access to these
abortion drugs and slipped it into her
tea and he's been thankfully convicted
of that but this is just one of many
examples where uh women have been kind
of forced into the abortion or
unknowingly forced and the more that we
make this available especially via
teleah Health where there isn't even a
confirmation or not necessarily tele
Health but over the internet where there
isn't even a confirmation that this
person is Pres pregnant the more danger
that we put women
in
secondly uh there is substantial
research that has followed up on the
safety and the on the safety of the
abortion pill and that research has
shown that it is much more dangerous
than than the FDA understood before and
U I also heard some comments on the uh
the Supreme Court case that Supreme
Court cases fundamentally that the f is
about the FDA not even following its own
safety protocols
um and I'm happy to get into that more
if you
wish so is that so the question is is
that the kind of society that we want to
live in where we're actually making it
easier
to um to force abortions on people who
don't want
them and and even so and if that is the
case should we be spending a dime of
public tax dollars on this I mean CVS
and Walgreens and Planned Parenthood
they all are in this business they
probably know much better how to ensure
uh access to it than we do as a state
and also why why should we be
subsidizing them with uh with with
public service announcements and those
types of things can't we do a better job
can't they do a better job and I guess
the last part is that the this is a
really a solution in search of a problem
we haven't heard that there actually is
a challenge if the Supreme Court says
that they have to go back to the
previous safety protocol because it's
safer um what are we going to do are we
going to go against the federal
government so uh and then the last thing
I just want to address is that we heard
about a shortage of obese the biggest re
reason we have a shortage is because we
are we have the lowest birth rate in the
nation um either lowest or second lowest
I mean if you want more people who take
care of babies and pregnant women you
need to have more babies um second it's
only a tiny minority of OBGYNs that
actually do abortions according to the
studies that I've seen thank you thank
you are there any representative Paz off
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question it's kind of two
parts so first I wonder what do you mean
by FDI not ifda not following their own
protocol and second part if I had it
correctly there were 5 million
applications of this drug so I would
expect we are better understanding now
uh if it's safe and what kind of uh side
effects it can cause
sure thank you representative so the can
you just remind me the first question
was uh about uh FDA not following their
own protocol when approving this drug
what do you mean by by thank you
representative so in in 2000 the FDA uh
May approved approved the abortion pill
under a protocol that is usually
reserved for extremely dangerous drugs
where you want to have a compromise
because you know something something
like a a a late stage cancer where the
the option of not giving anything is
actually going to be as dangerous as
giving this drug and it was approved
under that with no with with without
really good reasons being given the FDA
was challenged back in 2000 but they
decided to sit on the appeal for 16
years and then dismiss it and that is
the reason for this Supreme Court case
it's really trying to get the FDA to
follow its own rules and your second
question you said uh there's been five
million dosages so part of the problem
is that we haven't had very good
tracking uh so there isn't very good
linkage between let's say hemorrhaging
coming from the abortion pill and and
actually visits to the emergency room so
the best research that I've seen on this
did look at that they used I believe it
was California Medicaid data and they
and I believe that the number was
something like 15% of women experienced
hemorrhaging um there have been some
political attacks on this paper um and
as a researcher I'm happy to talk about
why it's very clear that these are
political attacks but in terms of the
actual research it seems it seems pretty
straightforward well thank you for
taking my
followup uh I haven't read that paper
maybe you know when when you're talking
about 15% experience in hemogen my
understanding is
uh um I I'm not a doctor but my
understanding like every abortion will
have some hmer
uh are you talking about some extreme
hammer or like what what those 15%
represent so representative I'd be happy
to send you the paper um my
understanding from memory is that the
hemorrhaging was it it had to be severe
enough to Warrant an emergency room
visit other
questions representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman and I
apologize for coming in late I was at
another committee so I only heard a
little bit of your testimony but have to
say what I did hear was alarming and one
of the things that I I believe I heard
you say was that a survey that you
referenced said 2third of women who had
abortions did not want to have abortions
well maybe you could clarify that for me
sure thank you for the question
representative uh the the survey that I
that I'm referring to found that 24% of
women reported uh that their abortion
was either coerced or forced uh and then
another I believe is 43%
said that it was inconsistent with their
values and so if you if you add those up
that's about 2ir of women who get
abortions um weren't really 100% in
waning
them would you be able to get us a
reference for the ab study or survey and
also well I it's not really a question
so I won't say it thank you other
questions seeing none okay thank you
thank you Mr
chair no one else has signed up to
testify on uh the Senate bill um 567 FN
does anyone else wish to
testify uh representative Shapiro can
us people
inition
people and representative wayon online
there's 99 in support for in opposition
and one
n okay all right that is the last uh
hearing we have scheduled today on a
Senate Bill I'm going to close the
public hearing on SB 567 FN uh and we
will convene next Wednesday for further
you
e